SENATE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS- AND EVERYONE HERE IN
THE GALLERY AS WE CONTINUE TO
TAKE SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN RISKS
THE SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME
THE PUBLIC IN ITS PROVIDED
ACCESS TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCES IMPATIENT FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OR IS THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODEIS POSTED
ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE ON THE
LINK TO TODAY'S HEARING AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE. FOUR ONE
EIGHT FIVE ACCESS CODE. FOUR SIX
SIX THREE NINE SIX EIGHT ONCE
AGAIN. 844-291-4185 ACCESS CODE. FOUR SIX SIX THREE NINE SIX
EIGHT I WILL ALSO MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL ASK
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO BE
PRESENT IN THE SENATE CHAMBER SO
WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM. AND
BEGIN OUR HEARING IT LOOKS LIKE
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE JUST LESS THAN
A QUORUM WE WILL BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE WE HAVE FOURTEEN BILLS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL'S LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL. CALL THE ROLL.
SARAH GONZALEZ HERE GONZALEZ
PRESENT CENTER BATES BATES
PRESENT CENTER ALAN. CENTER
ARCHULETA MARCH LETTER PRESENT
SENATE BECKER. CENTER CORTESE.
SENATOR DOLLY. SENATE DOT THAT
PRESENT. CENTER LIMON. SENATOR
MCGUIRE. SENATOR MELENDEZ
SENATOR MEN. MEN PRESENT CENTER
NEWMAN. IN PRESENT AND RUBIO.
CENTER SKINNER CENTER WHITE
HOUSE HE I KELSEY PRESENT CENTER
WILL. OKAY WE HAVE SEVEN MEMBERS
- SO JUST UNDER A QUORUM AT THIS
TIME SO- MEMBERS ITEMS TEN SB
TWELVE OH ONE FILE ITEM TEN MY
APOLOGIES SB TWELVE THE ONE BY
SENATOR MELENDEZ HAS BEEN PULLED
FROM TODAY'S HEARING BY THE
AUTHOR WE ALSO HAVE A CONSENT
CALENDAR CONSISTING OF THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS ITEM ONE S. C.
R. SEVENTY FIVE BY SENATOR
GROWTH ITEM THREE S. C. R.
SEVENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
RUSSELL. ITEM SIX AS THE R.
SIXTY BY SENATOR ARCHULETA ITEM
EIGHT- SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE ITEM NINE SB
ELEVEN NINETY THREE BY SENATOR
NEWMAN AND ITEM FIFTEEN SB
THIRTY NINETY BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ CAN I GET A MOTION
PLEASE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SENATOR BY CASKEY MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THANK YOU. ALL
MY APOLOGIES ALL RIGHT WELL THAT
WAS JUST PRACTICE THREE ALL
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
AT THIS TIME. I'M GLAD YOU'RE
ALL AWAKE AND LISTENING ALL
RIGHT- SO BEFORE WE- MOVE ON
HERE WE MENTIONED ABOUT SENATOR
MELISSA MELENDEZ IS A BILL BEING
HELD. AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE
ONE OTHER ANNOUNCEMENTS BEFORE
THE HEARING OF FROM OUR FIFTY
FOUR FIRST AUTHOR. TODAY WERE
BEING TELEVISED WITH A SINGLE
CAMERA THAT CANNOT SEE THE
PODIUM WHERE AUTHORS USUALLY
PRESENT. SO FOR TODAY WERE
ASKING AUTHORS TO COME UP AND
PRESENT FROM. THE FRONT FIRST
TASK UP HERE WHICH IS SENATOR
ARE TO LET US DESK SO THAT YOU
CAN BE SEEN ON TV. SO WE'LL ASK
SENATOR PORTANTINO AS OUR FIRST
MEMBER TO COME UP. AND WE'LL GET
STARTED AND THEN WE'LL GO BACK
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR THANK
YOU. WELCOME SENATOR PORTANTINO
YOU MAY PRESENT SB. NINE FIFTY
NINE. THE. THANK YOU A MATTER
MEMBER AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SAID TODAY I'M PRESENTING SP
NINE FIFTY NINE WHICH IS A
DISTRICT BILL SB NINE FIFTY NINE
LOOKS TO ALLOW SPECIFIC SURPLUS
PROPERTY IN THE CITY OF PAST
SOUTH PASADENA THAT IS OFFERED
FOR SALE TO SPECIFY TENANTS TO
BE OFFERED AT A TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN APPRAISAL VALUE SB NINE
FIVE NINE BILLS ON WORK TO GIVE
TENANTS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PURCHASE THEIR HOMES THIS IS
SOMETHING WE WANT TO GET
CALTRANS OUT OF THE PROPERTY
MANAGEMENT BUSINESS AND GET
THESE HOMES IN PRIVATE HANDS AND
ON THE TAX ROLLS- THIS IS A
SPECIAL CASE. AND THE TENANTS
WERE GIVEN AND RETURNED A NOTICE
OF CONDITIONAL OFFER PRIOR TO
THE SALE IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
BUT THESE ELIGIBLE RESIDENTS
SELL PROCESS WAS PAUSED DUE TO A
LEGAL CHALLENGE AND THEREFORE I
DON'T THINK THEY SHOULD BE
PENALIZED BECAUSE- SITUATIONS
OUTSIDE OF THEIR CONTROL BECAUSE
THE SALES TO BE HELD UP IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE TENANTS WERE
SURPRISED BY NEW NOTICE OF
CONDITIONAL OFFERS- WITH A NEW
INCREASE PRICE IN THE FIVE YEARS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN OUR
PRICES HAVE GONE UP FIFTEEN TO
EVEN 50% WITH ME ON THE PHONE I
HAVE SUZANNE ABNER WHO IS A
CALTRANS TENET AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WHEN YOU HAVE A QUORUM AND
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UNDER
PORTANTINO A MODERATOR WILL GO
TO. THE LINE FOR LEAD. TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIFTY NINE. THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY. OUR
FAMILY MOVED IN APRIL OF
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN TO LIVE IN
SOUTH PASADENA AND SEND THEIR
KIDS THE SOUTH PASADENA FOR WE
QUICKLY FOUND WHAT WITH THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AND THE COMMUNITY
AND THE HOUSE. FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OUR HOPE IS ALWAYS BEEN TO
PURCHASE A HOME IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE'RE THRILLED TO FIND A
NOTICE OF CONDITIONAL OFFER
PRIOR TO SALE WE WERE TOLD
CALTRANS WOULD CONDUCT AN
APPRAISAL AND THAT WOULD BE THE
PRICE THAT WE WOULD NEED FOR THE
HOUSE. W HIRED AN APPRAISER ON
OUR OWN AND THEY HAVE PAID THE
HOUSE IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
FIFTEEN AT ONE POINT TWO EIGHT
MILLION WE OBTAIN FINANCING AT
THAT PRICE EVEN WITH WEEKLY
CALLS TO CHECK THE STATUS THE
PRACTICE STALLED IN IT IS NOW
BEEN FIVE YEARS. IT'S
FRUSTRATING AT THE FONG RATE HAS
BEEN WE WERE PATIENT NOT
PURSUING HOME PURCHASES
ELSEWHERE BECAUSE VETERANS
REALTY GROUP THE REAL ESTATE
COMPANY HIRED BY CALTRANS WORK
WITH ATTENDANCE OFFICE AT THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN APPRAISED VALUE
WOULD BE WHAT. WE WOULD PAY NO
MATTER HOW LONG THE PROCESS. IN
MARCH OF TWO TWENTY CAROL
GAFFNEY FROM CAL. WE OUT OUR AND
EXPLAIN THE CALTRANS IS EAGER TO
UNLOAD THE TRUCK. AND THAT WE
WOULD RECEIVE A OFFER. ON
FAIRFAX IN ABOUT. WE WERE
CONCERNED WHEN CAL PROVIDED NO
APPRAISED VALUE AND ALL OF TWO
TWENTY. OF ONE POINT EIGHT NINE
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OVER 45%
HIGHER THAN WHAT WE WERE LED TO
BELIEVE AND PREPARED TO SPEND.
AT THIS TIME CAROLINE INFORMED
US THAT THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
APPRAISAL WAS ONE POINT THREE
FIVE MILLION. AT PURCHASE PRICES
HAVE ALSO STALLED WE HAVE RAISED
OUR FAMILY AND BUILT A LIFE HERE
WITH THEIR FRIENDS FAMILIES
SCHOOLS AND ACTIVITIES. IT WOULD
BE HEARTBREAKING AFTER LEAVE
BEHIND ALL THAT WE'VE BUILT HERE
WE ARE NOW IN OUR EARLY FIFTIES
AND CANNOT AFFORD THE HOUSE AT
ONE POINT EIGHT NINE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. HOWEVER WE CAN
STRETCH AND PAY THE CALTRANS
TWENTY FIFTEEN AFRAID RIGHT. ONE
POINT THREE FIVE MILLION ARE
DEVOTED TO PASSAGE SOUTH ALONG
TO OUR CHILDREN AS THEY ALSO
LEVER HOUSE IN THE COMMUNITY.
PLEASE DO NOT DISPLAY SAYS FROM
OUR HOME BECAUSE OF DELAYED SO
WE HAD NO CONTROL OVER WHICH OF
CARTER HOW CAN NO LONGER BE
AFFORDABLE FOR AYE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
MISS EVAN FEAR TED- AND NOW THAT
WE CONCLUDED LEE WITNESSES. AND
SUPPORT WILL GO TO THE GALLERY
FOR ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
NINE FIFTY NINE. C. NINE WE'LL
GO ON TO- BACK TO THE MODERATOR
FOR THE CONFERENCE LINE ANYONE
IN SUPPORT IN THE QUEUE FOR SB
NINE FIFTY NINE PLEASE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB DE AT
NINE FIFTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT
THE ONE AND THEN ZERO IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE FIFTY NINE. THE
MANAGER WE HAVE NOT PORTANTINO
AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND IT DOESN'T LOOK
LIKE THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION LEADER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION FOR SB NINE FIFTY
NINE SO WE'LL GO BACK TO THE
GALLERY AND THE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE. C. NINE WILL GO BACK TO
MODERATOR FOR ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION UP AT B. NINE FIFTY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR ANY OPPOSITION OF SB
NINE FIFTY NINE. AND MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU MODERATOR
SO WE'VE CONCLUDED SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WILL TAKE IT BACK TO.
THE CHAMBER FOR ANY MEMBERS
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SENATE
ARCHULETA MOVE THE BILL OKAY WE
HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
ARCHULETA ON S. B. NINE FIFTY
NINE AM THANK YOU SENATOR
PORTANTINO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AS WELL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE MEET. AT MISTER CONSULTANTS
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WE
HAVE A MOTION ON S. B. NINE
FIFTY NINE AND WE HAVE TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM BUT WE'RE
STILL. WAITING HERE. APOLOGIES
THANK YOU MISS A SENATOR
PORTANTINO WE HAVE A MEMBERS
COMING IN AND OUT SO THANK YOU.
WE WILL LEAVE THE FIVE FILE ON
CALL AT THIS MOMENT. ALL RIGHT.
OKAY OKAY NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR BY SENATOR
DORADO SB. THIRTEEN OH NINE.
YOU CAN COME UP HERE AND
PRESENTED THE FRONT DESK.
WELCOME CENTER THE RUSSELL THANK
YOU THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- FIRST I WANT TO THANK
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE ON THE
AMENDMENTS. TO CLARIFY
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW WHICH I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS WILL
ENSURE NEW SIGNS ARE SCREENED BY
CALTRANS AND ARE CONSISTENT WITH
THE FEDERAL LAW AND THE STATE'S
FEDERAL HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION
OBLIGATIONS. THE AMENDMENT WILL
CLARIFY THAT IF THE DEPARTMENT-
RAISES AN OBJECTION THEN THE
ADVERTISING DISPLAY MAY NOT BE A
WRECKED IT IF THE DEPARTMENT
DOES NOT RAISE AN OBJECTION-
WITHIN A TO BE AGREED UPON TIME
OF ALONG WITH A WRITTEN
JUSTIFICATION THEN THE
ADVERTISEMENT DISPLAY IS
PRESUMED TO BE DEEMED IN
COMPLIANCE. AND MAY BE WRECKED.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN OH NINE
WILL EXTEND THE ARENA EXEMPTIONS
IN THE OUTDOOR ADVERTISING ACT
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE A PATHWAY FOR
STADIUMS AND ARENAS TO PURSUE
FLEXIBLE REVENUE STREAMS AND NOT
RELY ON PUBLIC FUNDING THIS IS A
MAJOR HISTORIC CHANGE IN
FINANCING OF ARENAS AND
STADIUMS- SEVERAL YEARS AGO. OUR
CITIES AND COUNTIES DECIDED THAT
PUBLIC DOLLARS SHOULD NOT BE
USED TO BUILD THESE ARENAS AND
STADIUMS AND SO THEY HAD TO FIND
ALTERNATIVE FUNDING. THE ARENA
EXEMPTION WAS FIRST ESTABLISHED
BY THE LEGISLATURE- TO FUND THE-
HELP FUND THE CONSTRUCTION ON
THE OPERATIONS ON THESE ARE A
VERY IMPORTANT ECONOMIC AND
CULTURAL REGIONAL CENTERS
STADIUMS CREATE THOUSANDS OF
PERMANENT. AND CONSTRUCTION
JOBS- CREATE GENERATE MILLIONS
IN STATE AND LOCAL TAXES THE
STADIUMS IS ALSO PROVEN TO BE
VITAL PARTNERS IN OTHER WAYS. AS
GAMES WERE CANCELLED DURING THE
PANDEMIC MOST ARENAS BECAME
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS FOR THOSE
OF FOOD DISTRIBUTIONS AND PP
DISTRIBUTION AS WELL AS THE
VOTING CENTERS. IN MY DISTRICT
DODGER STADIUM FOR INSTANCE
TESTED MORE THAN ONE MILLION
ANGELENOS FOR CORONAVIRUS AND
BECAME ONE OF THE LARGEST COVERT
NINETEEN TESTING AND VACCINATION
SITES IN THE WORLD. OVER THE
YEARS THE ARENA EXEMPTION WAS
CLARIFIED AND EXTENDED TO GIVE
TEAMS AN OPPORTUNITYTO CONTINUE
THIS TYPE OF PROGRAMMING. THIRTY
NO SB THIRTEEN OH NINE WILL
EXTEND THE BENEFIT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED FOR
STADIUMS AND ARENAS THIS BILL
WILL ALSO REDUCE THE LENGTH OF
TIME FOR A MARKETING CONTRACT
FROM THE CURRENT ONE YEAR. TO A
GROUP OF A NUMBER OF DAYS TO BE
AGREED UPON WHICH WERE MORE
ACCURATELY. RB FLEX OUTDOOR.
OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE SAFEGUARDS
IN THE BILL TO PREVENT THE LOSS
OF FEDERAL HIGHWAY DOLLARS AND
ENSURE THAT ANY FUTURE ARENA
DISPLAYS DON'T VIOLATE OR OF
STATE OR FEDERAL LAW. IF THE
FEDERAL HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION
PROVIDES A NOTICE OF NON
COMPLIANCE THE SIGN MUST COME
DOWN. IN ADDITION ALL ARENA
BILLBOARD DISPLAYS MUST BE
APPROVED BY THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THEY ARE IN. AGAIN
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS MUCH
APPROVED MUST APPROVE AND THESE
ARE THE SAME ARE ENTITIES THAT
REVIEW AND APPROVE NON ARENA
BILLBOARDS SO THEY HELD TO THE
SAME STANDARD. ARENA OPERATORS
ARE NOT GRANTED ON UNREGULATED
PRIVILEGE THEY MUST COMPLY WITH
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW AND LOCAL
APPROVALS. OPPONENTS ARGUE THAT
THIS BILL PROVIDES A FINANCIAL
ADVANTAGE FOR SPORTS ARENA
BILLBOARDS IT IS IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT THERE ARE OVER
EIGHT THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
OUTDOOR BILLBOARDS IN THE STATE.
AND OF THOSE NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED
OR DIGITAL SIGNS THE MAXIMUM
NUMBER OF NEW BILLBOARDS THAT
COULD BE AUTHORIZED BY THIS LAW
REPRESENTS LESS THAN 1% OF ALL
OUTDOOR BILLBOARDS AND LESS THAN
FIVE PERCENT. OF NEWER DIGITAL
SIGNS THIS MASSIVE INDUSTRY WILL
NOT BE DISRUPTED THESE ARENA
BILLBOARDS CANNOT POSSIBLY DR
EXISTING OPERATORS OUT OF
BUSINESS BECAUSE THERE SIMPLY
AREN'T THAT MANY OF THEM.
REGARDLESS I REMAIN COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS I LOOK FORWARD TO WORK
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH- YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF TO ENSURE THAT
WE DO NOT JEOPARDIZE FEDERAL
HIGHWAY FUNDS. MADAM CHAIR TODAY
I HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN PERSON
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF BENNY
TRAN THE EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF CORPORATE STRATEGY.
ARE AT THE LOS ANGELES FOOTBALL
CLUB AND MARK THIS ALL SETTLED
THE CHIEF EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
OFFICER AT ATG. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR THE LAST ONE BEFORE
WE GET TO YOUR- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WE'RE GONNA ESTABLISH A
QUORUM BY MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT. NEW PLEASE ESTABLISH
A QUORUM PLEASE. SENATE ALLEN.
SENATOR BAKER. CENTER CORTESE
CORTESE PRESENT SENATOR DOLLY
DOLLY PRESENT CENTER LEMOND.
SENATOR MCGUIRE SENATOR MELENDEZ
. SENATOR RUBIO RUBIO PRESENT
CENTER SKINNER SAID AND WORK.
OKAY AND AS A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED THANK YOU MEMBERS-
SO NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- WE HAVE-
MISTER BENNY TRAN FROM THE LOS
ANGELES FOOTBALL CLUB AND BANC
OF CALIFORNIA STADIUM- YOU MAY
PROCEED PLEASE. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MANY TRANS I
AM AN EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT
OF LOS ANGELES FOOTBALL CLUB. I
AM PLEASED TO BE HERE ON BEHALF
OF LAFC IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN OH NINE. OUR
COPAYS IT'S HOME GAMES AT BACK
CALIFORNIA STADIUM IN DOWNTOWN
LOS ANGELES. SINCE THE TIME OF
OUR OPENING IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THIS FULLY PRIVATELY
FINANCED STADIUM HAS BECOME NOT
ONLY THE HOME TO LEADING I'M
LASTING. BUT IT HAS ALSO BECOME
AN IMPORTANT ECONOMIC AND
CULTURAL CENTER FOR THE REGION.
ONE THAN FLOYD AND EMPLOYS
THOUSANDS OF LOCAL WORKERS MANY
OF THEM REPRESENTING LOCAL
UNIONS. DURING THE HEAD OF THE
CODEPENDENT MAKE WHEN MLS GAMES
WERE CANCELLED THE STATE IT
BECAME A DISTRIBUTION CENTER FOR
THOSE IN NEED OF FOOD P. P. S.
AND SEVERAL ALSO HOSTED SEVERAL
VACCINE DRIVES. WE ALSO DURING
THE TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION. BECAME AN EARLY VOTING
CENTER. LIKE THE OTHER
PROFESSIONAL STADIUMS AND ARENAS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE TIED. TO THE
COMMUNITY R. D. I BELIEVE IT
WILL A RECOGNIZE OF THE VALUES
OF THESE LARGE COMPLEXES.
PROVIDED TO CALIFORNIA THAT LED
THE LEGISLATURE. TEN YEARS AGO
THAT AUTHORIZED STADIUMS LIKE
OURS. DIRECT TO OFFSITE
BILLBOARDS TO GENERATE
ADDITIONAL MARKING REVENUE. TO
ASSIST IN THE DEVELOPMENT AND
OPERATION OF THE STADIUMS. WHEN
THIS AUTHORIZATION WAS GRANTED
TO STADIUMS THE ADVERTISING WAS
REQUIRED TO BE PART OF A ONE
YEAR MARKING PLAN BETWEEN THE
STADIUM. AND ADVERTISER. IT WAS
BELIEVE. THIS WOULD PROVIDE
STAYS WITH A SIGNIFICANT REVENUE
BENEFIT. UNFORTUNATELY THE
APPROACH OF MARKETING
ADVERTISING HAS CHANGED. THE
OWNERS OF THE BUSINESS SERVICES
INCREASINGLY WANT SHORTER
DURATION. MORE TARGETED
MESSAGING WHICH A ONE YEAR LOW
LONG MARKETING PLAN MAY NOT A
COMEDY. STAVES ARE MISSING OUT
ON MUCH NEEDED REVENUE. THE BILL
CORRECT THAT SHORTCOMING BY ONLY
REQUIRING WORKING PLANTS TO BE
THIRTY DAYS IN LENGTH. AND THIS
IS PARTICULARLY ACUTE FOR MAJOR
LEAGUE SOCCER AS WE ARE NEWLY
NEW EARLY. AND FOR US AS A NEW
TEAM AND STADIUM- IN IN
CALIFORNIA AND LOS ANGELES. WE
ARE THE PATHWAY. TO BECOME
PROFITABLE BUT WE'RE NOT THERE
YET. IN ADDITION TO THAT DURING
THE TWO YEARS THE PANDEMIC.
SINCE WE RELY SOLELY ON REVENUE
THAT IS BASED ON ATTENDANCE WE
HAVE LOST TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. WE APPRECIATE THE
CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL TEAMS AND STADIUMS.
AND URGENT I ABOUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TRAN. AND NEXT WE HAVE
A SECOND LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES
MARTHA'S OF SEVERAL FROM ATG.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M MARTHA
SOCIO CHIEF EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
OFFICER FOR EIGHTEEN. ATG IS
PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN
OH NINE AND WE WANT TO THANK
SENATOR DORADO FOR INTRODUCING
THIS MEASURE. HEADQUARTERED IN
LOS ANGELES AG IS THE WORLD'S
LEADING SPORTS AND LIVE
ENTERTAINMENT COMPANY AGEE'S
DEVELOPED WORLD CLASS VENUES
LIKE CRYPTO DOT COM ARENA
FORMALLY KNOWN AS STAPLES CENTER
AS WELL AS MAJOR SPORTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT DISTRICT SUCH AS
ELLIE WHY. SB THIRTEEN OH NINE
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL CLARITY AND
FLEXIBILITY IN CONNECTION WITH
THE CONSTRUCTION AND OPERATION
OF STADIUMS AND ARENAS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WHICH
SERVE AS A MAJOR CATALYST FOR
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY. THE ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY GENERATED SUPPORTS
THOUSANDS OF GOOD PAYING UNION
JOBS BOTH DURING CONSTRUCTION
AND OPERATION. AND HAS A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON TOURISM
AND HOSPITALITY SECTORS
IMPORTANT ECONOMIC DRIVERS FOR
THE STATE. FREEWAY VISIBLE
SIGNAGE ON OR NEAR STADIUMS
ARENAS AND SPORTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT DISTRICTS HAVE
BECOME AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF
THE ECONOMIC FEASIBILITY OF NEW
STADIUM AND ARENA PROJECTS. AND
FOR RENOVATIONS OF THESE
FACILITIES WITHOUT THE RELIEF
OFFERED BY S. B. THIRTEEN OH
NINE THE CURRENT PROVISIONS AT
THE OUTDOOR ADVERTISING AT. ARE
LIKELY TO STIFLE FUTURE
CONSTRUCTION. ALTHOUGH SB
THIRTEEN OH NINE BROADENS THE
REACH AND IMPACT OF THE ARENA
EXEMPTION IT DOES NOT OPEN THE
DOOR FOR A PROLIFERATION OF
OUTDOOR SIGNAGE AROUND THE STATE
AND ITS APPLICABILITY IS LIMITED
ONLY TO PROFESSIONAL SPORTS
VENUES. CONCERNS BY COMMITTEE
STAFF HAVE BEEN RAISED REGARDING
THE POTENTIAL IMPACT OF SUCH
LEGISLATION ON FEDERAL AID
HIGHWAY FUNDING. NO ONE
CERTAINLY NOT AG WANTS TO IMPACT
FEDERAL AID HIGHWAY FUNDING WE
ACCEPT THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF OFFERED TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS REGARDING THEIR
CONCERNS THEIR CONCERNS. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE TO APPROVE SB THIRTEEN
OH NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR TESTIMONY THAT
CONCLUDES LEAD- TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. AND NOW MOVE ON TO
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY WHO'D LIKE
TO SUPPORT S. B. NOT. EXCUSE ME
SB THIRTEEN OH NINE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ANGIE MINUTE HERE IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
DODGERS THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
IN THE GALLERY WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN TO NINE
HUNDRED GOVERNOR IN HALF THE SAN
FRANCISCO FORTY NINERS WE
APOLOGIZE WE DO NOT GET OUR
LETTER OF SUPPORT IN TIME BUT WE
ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON
BEHALF OF THE OATH OAKLAND
ATHLETICS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN THE
GALERY IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN OH NINE. RIGHT SEE NONE
SO MODERATE WILL TAKE IT BACK TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE AND FOR
ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO SUPPORT SB
THIRTEEN OH NINE PLEASE. THANK
YOU FOR IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN OH NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS THE
ONE AND THEN ZERO IF YOU AREN'T
SUPPORT AT THE. THIRTEEN OH
NINE. AND MENTOR WE HAVE KNOWING
TUNE UP AT THIS TIME FOR SUPPORT
OKAY THANK YOU- NOW WILL TURN IT
TO LEAD OPPOSITION WE DO HAVE
TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. OF
BOTH HERE IN PERSON THE FIRST AS
MEGAN LOPER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE OUTDOOR ADVERTISING
ASSOCIATION- IF YOU'D LIKE TO
COME UP AND TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN OH
NINE. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS REMEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MEGHAN LOW FOR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
OUTDOOR ADVERTISING ASSOCIATION.
HOW WE REMAIN RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO SB THIRTEEN OH NINE
AND DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
COMMENTS. ABOUT THE AMENDMENTS
AND WE HAVEN'T HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE A REVIEW THAT
LANGUAGE BUT AT FROM THE
DISCUSSION HERE IT SOUNDS LIKE.
HAD THEY TAKEN MEANINGFUL STEPS
TO LOOK AT FEDERAL COMPLIANCE
FOR FUTURE SIGNS BUT WE REMAIN
CONCERNED WITH SIGNS THAT ARE
EXISTING. THAT HAVE FEDERAL
VIOLATIONS AND THE CSAA HAS
REPRESENTED LICENSE OUTDOOR
ADVERTISERS HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN. AND OUR MEMBERS DO
REPRESENT BOTH SMALL FAMILY
OWNED INDEPENDENT OPERATORS AND
LARGER NATIONAL COMPANIES DOING
BUSINESS HERE IN THE STATE. OUR
MEMBERSHIP REPRESENTS ABOUT 90%
OF THE BILLBOARD FACES THAT YOU
SEE THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S COMMENTS
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING SIGNS AND THE- BIG
QUESTION AS TO WHETHER OR NOT.
THIS MEANS THAT ARENA SIGNS-
REALLY POSE A THREAT
RESPECTFULLY WE WOULD- SUBMIT
THAT THEY DO GIVEN THAT ARENA
SIGNS ARE OPERATING IN MANY
CASES AT SIZES THAT ARE BEYOND
WHAT IS ALLOWED UNDER FEDERAL
LAW. AND HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
OFFER CROSS PROMOTIONAL
MARKETING ACTIVITIES THAT GIVES
ADVERTISERS A RETURN ON
INVESTMENT THAT A SINGLE SIGN.
I'M ON MY WAY CAN OFFER. I WE
LOOK FORWARD TO TAKE. TO WORK
WITH THE SPONSORS- BUT
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS RAISED
IN THE ANALYSIS THAT YOU TALK
ABOUT THE THREATS TO FEDERAL
FUNDING WE DO FEEL THAT THE
MARKETING PLAN WHO WAS A
RECOGNITION THAT ARENA SIGNS
WERE RECEIVING SPECIAL TREATMENT
AND BEING. ALLOWED TO BE
ARRESTED IN OP AND PLACES THAT
ARE AT LICENSE BILLBOARD
OPERATORS WERE NOT ABLE TO SPEAK
PERMITS FOR. AND WE DO FEEL THAT
THAT MARKETING PLAN WAS AN
ATTEMPT TO LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD AND BY CHANGING. AND
ELIMINATING THAT DOWN TO THIRTY
DAYS THAT PUTS THESE FINES IN
DIRECT COMPETITION WITH OUR
MEMBERSHIP. AT RESPECTFULLY WE
MUST AT THIS TIME REMAIN OPPOSED
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS LOPER.
I NEXT OUR OUR LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS NUMBER TWO IS MISTER
STEVE CRUZ WITH OF THE ALLEY OF
DORE MR CRUISE YOU MAY BEGIN
YEAH. A GOOD MORNING MENTION
MEMBER STEVE RUZ AND I
REPRESENT A NUMBER OF THE SMALL
AND MEDIUM SIZED- BILLBOARD
COMPANIES THAT OPERATE IN
CALIFORNIA. I WOULD ECHO SOME OF
THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE SLOPER-
GET PRETTY THE COMMENTS BY- THE
COMMITTEE RECOGNIZING COUPLE
ISSUES WHICH IS ONE- THE
UNFAIRNESS AND HEAR AN
UNFAIRNESS OF. THE DYNAMICS THAT
YOU CREATE AND APPROVING WHAT WE
CALL THESE ONE UP BILLBOARD
EXEMPTIONS- AND THE REALITY IS
THE SMALL COMPANIES HAVE ALSO
BEEN IMPACTED BY CODE LIKE A LOT
OF OTHER BUSINESSES INDUSTRIES.
AND SO WE'RE COMPETING FOR THAT
SAME FINITE NUMBER OF
ADVERTISING REVENUES AND IF YOU
HAVE THE CHOICE TO BE ON THE
SITE LOCATED PROBABLY ON A
FREEWAY AND IT'S TEN TIMES
LARGER THAN THE ONE. SIX BLOCKS
IN THAT'S UNFAIR ADVANTAGE AND
SO- I THINK THAT'S OUR PRIMARY
CONCERN ALSO WHEN THEY'RE
READING EXEMPTION WAS APPROVED
IT WAS APPROVED AT IT WAS A
TEMPORARY IN NATURE RIGHT TO
ASSIST IN THE FINANCE OF THE
STADIUM. AND THE PROPONENTS COME
BACK IN ONE EXTEND THAT SO IN
OUR MIND IF YOU DO IT FOR THIS
BILL YOU'LL HAVE TEN MORE THIS
YEAR NEXT YEAR AND IT MAY NOT BE
FOR THE RETAIL. BEFORE SOME
OTHER EXEMPTIONS OUT. WE HAVE
RELEASED TO HOLD THE- BECAUSE WE
PLAY BY THE RULES WE THINK
OTHERS PLAY BY THE RULES AND SO.
UNFAIR A PLANE FIELD I THINK IS
A ISSUE I- THAT WE HOPE THAT YOU
CONSIDER I THINK THE OTHER IS ON
THE FEDERAL HIGHWAY- DOLLARS AT
RISK AGAIN THAT'S A REAL ISSUE
THERE'S BEEN- COMMUNICATION FROM
FHWA IN THAT REGARD. AND SO
RECEIVE THEM AND IF THEY WERE
SUGGESTED BY THE COMMITTEE-
WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
THAT PROPONENTS BUT AGAIN WITH
THIS POINT WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU MR CRUISE SO
IF CONCLUDED EARLY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTY NINE SO
WE'LL TAKE IT TO THE GALLERY
ANYONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY WOULD
LIKE TO- TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB THIRTEEN OH
NINE PLEASE. C. NINE MODERATOR
WILL TAKE IT BACK TO YOU TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN OH
NINE PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION UP AT THE THIRTEEN OH
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE. THEN
ZERO. AGAIN AT ONE NINE ZERO IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION SB.
THIRTEEN OH NINE. AND I'M SURE
WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION TO IT THIS
TIME OKAY THANK YOU WE'VE
CONCLUDED SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
SO WE'LL TAKE THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO MEMBERS SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MANAGER I'D
LIKE TO COMPLIMENT THE AUTHOR-
FOR TAKING THE AMENDMENT AND THE
AMENDMENT IS JUST FOR CD. JUST
MINUTES AGO OBVIOUSLY ADDRESSES
THE FEDERAL VIOLATIONS THAT
MIGHT OCCUR- BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE FACT IS THAT-
IT'S BEEN STATED THAT IF THERE
IS ANY VIOLATION OF FEDERAL LAW.
THAT THE ADVERTISEMENT OR THE
DISPLAY. OF THE APPARATUS
WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE THE
BILLBOARD ITSELF WILL BE
REMOVED. AND CONSEQUENTLY
REMOVING ANY CHALLENGE- FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND- WOULD
NOT AFFECT OURSELVES IN THE
STATE. IN VIOLATION AS WELL OR
THE CITIES AND I THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
COMPLIMENT THE FACT THAT YOU HAD
MENTIONED THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION- TO- LOOK AGAIN AT
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT STILL
MIGHT REMAIN. WHICH PERTAIN TO
DISTANCE THE ADVERTISEMENT OF
CERTAIN ITEMS WITHIN THE STADIUM
OUTSIDE THE STADIUM SO I HOPE
THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO DO THAT AND
THIS IS WHY I'M IN A- AGREED TO
MOVE THE BILL- UNDER COMMITTEE
SO YOU CAN CONTINUE WORKING.
WITH THE OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR THANK YOU SEVEN
ARCHULETA ANYMORE. A MEMBERS OF
CENTER RUBIO. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. YOU KNOW I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL AND- YOU KNOW FIRST OF ALL
I WANTED KNOWLEDGE EVERYTHING
THAT THEY'RE RINOS HAVE DONE.
DURING THE COVER TIMES UNITED IT
WAS ALREADY EXPRESSED YEAR- I
KNOW THAT THEY BECAME- CENTERS
FOR VACCINATION SITES AND THEY
PROVIDED A LOT OF BENEFITS TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. WHICH IS
COMMENDABLE- BUT I CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONCERNS ON THIS BILL AND
PERHAPS COMING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT I HAD. EMAILED A
NEGOTIATED SEVERAL LOCAL
CONTRACTS ON WITH BILLBOARDS AND
I DO KNOW- BASED ON THE ANALYSIS
OF THIS COMMITTEE YOU KNOW IT
DOES POSE A SOMEWHAT OF A
UNFAIR. COMPETITION ACCORDING TO
THE ANALYSIS THAT I HAVE RIGHT
BEFORE ME IT SAYS THE ARENA
EXTENSION WAS ORIGINALLY
ESTABLISHED TO HELP. FUND NEW
SPORTS ARENAS BOTH CONSTRUCTION
AND OPERATIONS. ACCORDING TO THE
ANALYSIS IS SAYS THIS BILL WILL
INCREASE THE BILLBOARD
ADVERTISING REVENUES OF THESE
ALREADY SUCCESSFUL ORGANIZATIONS
HOWEVER THIS NEW REVENUE COMES
AT THE EXPENSE OF THE
TRADITIONAL OUTDOOR ADVERTISING
COMPANIES. AND THE COMMITTEE
WANTED TO JUST STATE THAT THAT
SHOULD BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION. AND SO I'M A
LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT THAT
ADVANTAGE THAT WILL BE PLACED
AND DISADVANTAGED TO SMALLER-
BILLBOARD. COMPANIES AND I KNOW
THAT THE INTENT IS THERE WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
SUCCESSFUL WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY CONTINUE TO EMPLOY
PEOPLE. I MEAN THE REALITY IS
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN GOING TO
DODGER GAMES SINCE I WAS A
LITTLE GIRL AND I YOU KNOW I'VE
ALWAYS KNOWN HIM TO BE
SUCCESSFUL EVEN BEFORE
BILLBOARDS YOU KNOW THE BIG.
BRIGHT ONES THAT WE SEE NOW AND
FREEWAYS AND I BELIEVE THAT THEY
WILL CONTINUE TO BE SUCCESSFUL
AND FOR ME AS I WANT THIS
CONVERSATION TO IS. TO SOMEHOW
INCLUDE THOSE SMALLER BILLBOARDS
RIGHT NOW I'M JUST BASED ON THE
FIRST- SUPPORTER I'M SORRY YOUR
LEAD WITNESS YOU KNOW THIS IS
WHAT HE SAID THIS BILL WILL
HELP. GENERATE ADDITIONAL
REVENUES STADIUMS ARE MISSING
OUT ON SIGNIFICANT REVENUES WE
ARE NOT PATHWAY TO BECOME
PROFITABLE- BUT WE'RE NOT THERE
YET AND STILL THE CONVERSATION
REVOLVES. A LOT AROUND
PROFITABILITY AND I THINK THAT.
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
GOOD PAYING JOBS BECAUSE THEY
NEED TO THEIR LARGE INSTITUTIONS
THAT RELY ON GOOD PAYING JOBS TO
KEEP THAT NEED A STADIUM COINED
THE WORKFORCE WILL BE THERE THE
PROFITS WILL BE THERE IT'S JUST
A MATTER OF HOW MUCH. MY
PERSONAL CONCERN IS I WANT TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL BUT I NEED
MORE CONVERSATION ABOUT SMALLER
COMPANIES WHAT ARE WE DOING FOR
THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
NOT. AT A DISADVANTAGE AND I DO
BELIEVE THIS IS UNFAIR
COMPETITION. I WANT TO BE
SUPPORTIVE RIGHT NOW I'M GONNA
HAVE TO LAY OFF BUT I'M
ABSOLUTELY OPEN TO HEARING WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO FOR THE SMALLER
COMPANIES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO AND I THINK A
SENATOR THAT ALSO CAN EXPLAIN IN
HER CLOTHES AND SO SENATOR
AKOWSKI NEXT THANK YOU MANAGER-
I'M- THE OPPOSITION RAISES
CONCERNS ABOUT THE CURRENT SIGNS
THAT MAY BE OUT OF FEDERAL
COMPLIANCE. BECAUSE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT I HAVE TALKED TO
. BY THREE ERECTING THE THAT THE-SIGNS THAT THE DEPARTMENT WOULD
BE ABLE TO CALTRANS WE WILL SAY
NO YOU CAN'T DO THAT IN USING
THE CRITERIA OF WHETHER IT'S
TWELVE HUNDRED SQUARE FEET TWO
CLICK LOCATED TO CLOSE IT
ANOTHER SIGN OR ON DISPLAY IN
FULL MOTION PICTURES AS A SORT
OF A IDEAS THAT THEY'RE LOOKING
AT SO IT'S PRETTY ESY TO
DETERMINE WHETHER IT'S TWELVE
HUNDRED SQUARE FEET OR TO CLOSE
. SO MY QUESTION IS THAT SINCE
WE'RE RE AUTHORIZING THE EXPIRED
SPECIAL PROVISIONS THIS THE
AUTHOR THINKS. THAT THE
EFFECTIVE DATE AND THE OTHER
DISCRETIONARY APPROVAL POWERS
SAID WE'RE GIVING TO THE
CALTRANS WITH THIS AMENDMENT IS
ENOUGH FOR THEM TO. ENFORCE ANY
PERCEIVED VIOLATIONS CURRENTLY
AND SIGNS THAT ALREADY EXIST.
THANK YOU CENTER AKOWSKI AND I
THINK THAT'S A QUESTION SOCIETY
RATHER DO IT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ANSWER THAT NOW- WHEN YOU'RE
CLOSE. I THINK IN MY CLOTHES I
COULD PUT BUT BECAUSE OKAY AND
THEN. THE OTHER QUESTION MADAM
CHAIR IF I COULD USE THAT- AFTER
THIS ANSWER RECTITUDE I GUESS
THE QUESTION IS THAT I GET. THE
TWELVE HUNDRED FEET YOU CAN DEAL
WITH THAT YOU CAN DEAL WITH TOO
CLOSE TO EACH OTHER BUT THEN
DISPLAYING FULL MOTION PICTURES
EVEN THOUGH. IT'S ONLY 5% OF THE
SIGNS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE THESE
VIDEO THINGS HOW DO HOW THIS
CALTRANS POLICE IF SOME. PERSON
WAS DOING MOTION PICTURE WHEN
YOU'RE ONLY SUPPOSED TO DO STILL
ADDS WITH REGARD TO FEDERAL LIFE
GETS ITS IT'S IN COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE LAW BUT HOW WOULD WE
ENFORCE. THAT PROVISION OR IS.
AGAIN THIS DISCRETIONARY
APPROVAL ANOTHER FOR THEM TO GO
NGUYEN POSTER ACTION AND REMEDY
YET. THANK YOU SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI AT SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU- MADAM CHAIR I WOULD
LIKE TO ALSO COMPLEMENT THE
AUTHOR I KNOW THAT YOU'VE DONE A
LOT OF WORK ON THIS TRYING TO
BRING THE TWO SIDES TOGETHER IN
ENSURE THERE'S FAIR NOW SPENT. I
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE SENATOR RUBIO I THINK
THAT THEY UNFAIR ADVANTAGE- IS
REALLY VERY COMPELLING ARE TO
OFFER ME TO CONTINUE TO OPPOSE
THAT WITH THE HOPES THAT AS IT
GOES FORWARD. I YOU'LL REALLY BE
ADDRESSING THAT AND CERTAINLY
THE QUESTIONS RAISED BY SENATOR
WIECKOWSKI THOSE ARE ALL OF THE
COMPELLING NATURE. IN TERMS OF
SETTING A PRECEDENT I EVEN
THOUGH IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE TERM
THESE THINGS CONTINUE AND
CONTINUE AND ARE CERTAINLY I'M
CONCERNED IT DRIVES OUR
TRADITIONAL. FOLKS OUT OF
BUSINESS SO- I WILL REMAIN
OPPOSED TODAY BUT WITH THE HOPES
THAT WHEN IT REACHES. THE FLOOR
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE- AT
THAT POINT IN TIME A COMPROMISE
THAT WORKS FOR BOTH SIDES OF THE
EQUATION. THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES CENTER MELENDEZ. I'M THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I THINK
SOMETIMES BECAUSE WE'RE DOING
THESE COMMITTEE HEARINGS ON THE
FLOOR WE- ASSUME THAT THE
PROCEEDINGS IN THE FORMALITIES
ARE LIKE WHEN WE ARE IN SESSION
BUT WEARING COMMITTEE AND SO THE
QUESTION IS BEING ASKED OF THE
OTHER IMPORTANT FOR THEM TO BE
ANSWERED AT THE TIME THEIR ASSET
MAY PRECIPITATE EVEN MORE
QUESTIOS I WOULD JUST ASK THAT-
SENATOR DORADO. ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS IT'S IN A WHITE CAL
SKI ASK BECAUSE- THE ANSWERS TO
THOSE QUESTIONS MIGHT LEAD TO
MORE SO THAT WE CAN PROPERLY VET
THIS BILL IN THIS COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
MELENDEZ SENATOR ALSO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS. AND I CAN ALSO-
CLARIFY SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS
JUST I THINK EVERYONE HAS THE
AMENDMENTS ON THEIR DESK A
PROVIDED BAR CHIEF CONSULTANT.
BUT THE PROPOSED WHAT THE BILL
DOES AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED
THREE THINGS TWO OF THEM ARE
UNCHANGED AT THE HIP AND HAD
BEEN DEBATED. THE FIRST ENSURES
THAT FUTURE ARENA BILLBOARDS ARE
COMPLIANT WITH STATE AND FEDERAL
LAW BY REQUIRING CALTRANS PRE
APPROVED IN IN AN UNSPECIFIED
NUMBER OF DAYS OF THAT IS GOING
TO BE NEGOTIATED. WING FORWARD-
EXTENDS ARENA SUNSET UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. IT REDUCES
THE MINIMUM DURATION OF THE
ARENA MARKETING PLAN TO THIRTY
DAYS FROM ONE YEAR STILL BEING
DISCUSSED- AND IN TERMS OF THE-
CITY I BELIEVE SENATOR CASKEY
MENTION THE- CALTRANS
ENFORCEMENT ISSUE THERE. THERE
THIS BILL DOESN'T ADDRESS THE
ENFORCEMENT ISSUE. THIS IS OF
COURSE NOT YOU KNOW NEW
BILLBOARDS- BUT- THERE HAD BEEN
VIOLATIONS IN THE PAST AND SO WE
NEED TO- GET CLEARED I THINK
MOVING FORWARD FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE- ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS WILL
BE FOR CALTRANS MOVING FORWARD
IF THIS BILL SHOULD PASS OUT OF
COMMITTEE- BUT SENATOR RAZA
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD
ADDITIONAL. INFORMATION SURE I
MEAN I THINK WITH REGARDS TO THE
UNFAIR COMPETITION- AGAIN AND I
MENTIONED THIS EARLIER- THE
NUMBER OF SIGNS THAT EXIST
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SPREAD ALL
OVER THE STATE. OF IS MASSIVE
EIGHT THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
SCIENCE- WE'RE TALKING HERE LESS
THAN ONE PERCENT. OF WHAT WOULD
BE THE NUMBER THAT COULD BE
AUTHORIZED BY BY THIS EXTENSION-
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE-
ARGUMENT. THAT IN THESE VERY
LIMITED LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT IS GOING TO CREATE
SUCH A DISADVANTAGE- THAT'S ONE
THE SECOND THING IS I REMEMBER
THAT THERE HAVE TO BE LOCAL
APPROVALS ARE HAS TO BE LOCAL
ORDINANCE. THAT THEY ALSO- HAVE
TO GO FORWARD AND GET- BEFORE
THEIR LOCAL ENTITIES. SO THEY
HAVE TO THE ARENA BILL BOARDS
ALSO HAVE TO GET THAT- THAT
APPROVAL SO- THE NUMBERS TO SHOW
THEY'RE NOT UNFAIR COMPETITION-
THE WAY IN WHICH THEAPPROVALS
HAVE TO BE DONE. SHOWS THAT THEY
HAVE TO JUMP THROUGH THE HOOPS
JUST LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE- AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE- WHAT ELSE
TO SAY ABOUT THAT- WITH REGARDS
TO ENFORCEMENT AS YOU SAID MADAM
CHAIR- THIS IS. IN CALTRANS
HANDS WE- THIS OF- EXTENSION OF
THIS BILL DOES- OF THIS
EXEMPTION. IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO IMPACT THE
ENFORCEMENT THE ARGUMENT WAS
MADE THAT THERE ARE SOME SIGNS
OUT THERE THAT COULD BE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE. WE DECIDED OKAY
LET'S DEAL WITH IT MOVING
FORWARD SO THAT'S HOW WE ADDRESS
THAT- AND I. I DON'T KNOW WHICH
OTHER QUESTIONS MADAM CHAIR OKAY
THANK YOU SENATOR RUSSELL.
SENATOR WILL GO TO SENATOR ALAN
AND THEN COME BACK TO CENTER
MELENDEZ SENATOR ALAN. YEAH
THANK YOU FOR THIS DISCUSSION- I
YOU KNOW I HAVE LESS OF A
PROBLEM CONCEPTUALLY OUT OF WITH
THIS BILL IN THE SENSE I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT. AREAS AROUND
STADIA- I DON'T THINK THAT THE
TYPES O PLACES. WHERE I THIS
BILL ENVISIONS ADDITIONAL
ADVERTISING WITH THE KINDS OF
PLACES THAT LADY BIRD JOHNSON
HAD MINE WHEN SHE PUSHED THE
LEGISLATION THE FIRST PLACE. I
WILL SAY ONE THING THOUGH AND I
DON'T AND I KNOW. THAT THE
AMENDMENTS HELP A LITTLE BIT IN
THIS PLACE BUT I DON'T THINK GO
FAR ENOUGH. AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT. WERE ALREADY IN VIOLATION
OF FEDERAL LAW- THROUGH EXISTING
PROGRAMS BUT YOU KNOW WE'RE
TAKING ON A RISK HERE. ARE BY
DOUBLING DOWN ON THIS SYSTEM ON
ON THIS APPROACH. I DON'T I
DON'T HAVE A- UP A CONCEPTUAL
PROBLEM WITH. THE APPROACH I YOU
KNOW FROM MY PERSPECTIVE. THE
DRIVE AROUND DODGER STADIUM OR
OR THE ONE TEN FREEWAY OR ANGEL
STADIUM THAT'S NOT THE TYPE OF.
BEAUTIFUL GREEN WAY THE LABOR
JOHNSON TRY TO PROTECT. IT SO I
DON'T MIND IF THERE'S NEW MORE
ADVERTISING RIGHT AROUND THAT
STADIUM IT'S FINE TO ME BUT- I
THINK THAT THE FOLKS WHO ARE
MAKING MONEY OFF OF THIS OUGHT
TO BE HELPING TO. PAY THE STATE
A LITTLE BIT TO HELP COMPENSATE
US FOR THE RISK THAT WE'RE
TAKING. ASSOCIATED WITH OUR FOR
OUR HOW ARE HIGHLY FUNDS BECAUSE
THE END OF THE DAY THE
ACCOUNTABILITY COMES TO US AND
NOT TO THE FOLKS. WHO COULD BE
VIOLATING THE LAW- ON THE GROUND
AND I WANT TO BRING THAT UP AND
I JUST WANT TO SHARE THIS WITH
MY COLLEAGUES YOU KNOW IT IT
SEEMS LIKE THE STATE'S NOT
TAKING ON. THIS THERE'S NO
UPSIDE TO THE STATE HERE IN
SPITE OF THE BIG RISK THAT WE'RE
TAKING ON AS WE CONTINUE TO
DOUBLE DOWN. ON THIS APPROACH.
AND I LOVE YOU KNOW IF THE IF
THE IF THE CHAIR THE AUTHOR HAVE
COMMENTS ON THAT I WOULD
CERTAINLY LOVE TO HEAR. WHAT IT
. IF I COULD. HERE TO DROP- THE
ROUTE WE'RE ADDRESSING THE RISK
IN A WAY THAT'S NOT BEEN
ADDRESSED THERE HASN'T BEEN
LANGUAGE THIS IS MUCH STRONGER
LANGUAGE THAN WHAT EXISTS NOW AS
FAR AS CALTRANS RESPONSIBILITIES
WE'RE GIVING MORE TEETH TO THEM
SAYING IF YOU GET A NOTICE. IF
YOU GET A NOTICE FROM THE STATE
AND- LET ME JUST BACK UP THERE
IS NO THERE ARE BEEN NO SPECIFIC
NOTICES THAT ARE BROUGHT TO AND
BEEN BROUGHT TO ANYBODY'S
ATTENTION THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS ISSUED SO AS FAR
AS WITH. WE KNOW YOUR IT THEY
AREN'T ANY GOING ANY SPECIFIC
NOTICES BUT MOVING FORWARD IF US
UP A NOTICE IS GIVEN BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT THERE'S
A VIOLATION THE DEPARTMENT HAS
THE RIGHT TO. TAKE IT DOWN THE
CALTRANS HAS A RIGHT TO TAKE IT
DOWN I MEAN THAT'S MORE POWER
THAN THEY'VE EVER HAD- SO WE
AGREED TO DO THAT EVEN THOUGH
THERE'S NO PROOF THAT OR
EVIDENCE THAT. BY PUTTING UP
SOME MORE SIGNS THAT THAT'S
GOING TO MEAN THAT THE SIGNS ARE
ALL IN VIOLATION OF FEDERAL LAW
WE'RE SAYING IS OKAY IF THERE'S
A CONCERN ABOUT THAT LET'S
ADDRESS IT LET'S GIVE MORE POWER
TO CALTRANS AND THEY'LL BE ABLE
TO TAKE DOWN A DISPLAY IF
THERE'S A NOTICE BEING GIVEN TO
IF THERE'S A THREAT IF THEY
THINK THERE'S A THREAT. OF
LOSING FIVE OF FEDERAL FUNDS
THEY CAN TAKE IT DOWN SO THERE'S
A WAY TO CURE THE PROBLEM- IN A
WAY THAT STRONGER THAN IS EVER
UP THERE WE'VE EVER HAD AND WE
SEE TAKE IT DOWN WHO PAYS FOR
TAKING IT DOWN. THE AT
ADVERTISER. SO THEY AND THEY CAN
COMPEL. YES I CAN SAY CRIMINAL
PENALTIES IF THEY DON'T DO IT
WHAT WHAT'S THE MECHANISM BY
WHICH THEY THEY'RE- THEY'RE
TAKING DOWN THE SIGN. THEY SAY
YOU HAVE TO TAKE IT DOWN. I
WOULD HAVE A DOMINO WHAT. IS
WHAT WHAT'S THE MECHANISM I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE'VE GOT
DIFFERENT WAYS I'M JUST TRYING
TO STAY WITH THE MECHANISMS FOR
ENFORCEMENT AND WE DID IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL WE DON'T GET ANY
MORE DETAIL ON THAT OTHER THAN
TO GIVE VERY EXPLICIT DIRECTION
THAT CALTRANS CAN ORDER THEM TO
TAKE IT DOWN. OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR RAWSON AS WE MENTIONED
BEFORE THINK WITH- THE AUTHORS
MENTIONING IS THERE'S STILL A
LOT TO BE DEBATED- BUT- IN THE
FIRST AMENDMENT PROVIDED TO YOU-
INSURES THAT FUTURE RINA
BILLBOARDS ARE COMPLIANT WITH
STATE FEDERAL OTHER REQUIRING
CLUB CALTRANS PRE APPROVED- IN
AN UNSPECIFIED NUMBER OF DAYS
BUT- THE NUMBER OF DAYS IS ONLY
WHAT. IS ADDRESSED IN THE BILL
OR WILL BE ADDRESSED MOVING
FORWARD NOT THE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM BUT AGAIN SOMETHING
THAT COULD BE DISCUSSED AND I
THINK THAT- YOU KNOW AS WE'RE
DEBATING THIS OF COURSE LOTS OF
QUESTIONS AND OPINIONS ON THIS.
WE DO HAVE THE AUTHORITY HAS ITS
COMMITTEE TO BRING THIS THIS
BILL BACK SHOULD WE HAVE MORE
ADDITIONAL YOU KNOW MORE
QUESTIONS AN ADDITIONAL-
COMMENTS TO BE MADE ON THIS BUT-
THAT IS- I TRUST THAT THE AUTHOR
IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO MAKE.
INROADS WITH BOTH SIDES SO WITH
THAT SAID- SENATOR MELENDEZ WILL
GO BACK TO YOU AND THEN WE'LL
GO. TO SENATOR MEN. I'M THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR SO. A COUPLE OF
THINGS YOU KNOW. WE HAVE BILLS
TO COME THROUGH COMMITTEE AND IT
IS VERY COMMON FOR THERE TO BE A
FEW TWEAKS THAT NEED TO BE MADE
A FEW ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED THAT AREN'T MAJOR
CHANGES BUT ARE RATHER MINOR
CHANGES WERE DISSATISFIED- SOME
OF THE OPPOSITION. BUT IT IS
INCUMBENT ON US AS LEGISLATORS
IN THIS COMMITTEE TO PROPERLY
VET THESE BILLS AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE NOT PASSING BILLS.
THAT ARE FILLED WITH HOLES AND
HAVE MAJOR PROBLEMS RELATING TO
THE CORE ISSUE THAT THE BILL IS
TRYING TO ADDRESS AND THAT IS
WHAT I SEE. WITH THIS BILL IT IS
. IT MAKES NO SENSE FOR US TO
PUSH BILLS FORWARD THAT WE KNOW.
AREN'T READY WITH THE HOPES OF
AT SOME POINT DOWN THE ROAD IT
WILL GET FIXED BECAUSE WHAT
HAPPENS- TOO OFTEN IS IT BECOMES
A MESS. IN THE OTHER HOUSE AND
THEN IT'S- I MEAN THAT'S NOT THE
PROPER WAY. TO DO OUR JOBS HERE
SO I THINK THIS BILL IS. IS NOT
READY TO MOVE FOR YET THAT IS MY
OPINION I WILL ADD ON. THOUGH
THAT THE SMALLER TRADITIONAL
OUTDOOR ADVERTISING COMPANIES-
YOU KNOW AREN'T BEING GIVEN THE
SAME ADVANTAGE. THAT YOU ARE
GIVING THESE OTHERS IN YOUR BILL
AND WE SEE THAT TIME AND TIME
AGAIN. PARTICULARLY WITH-
SPORTING ARENAS AND ATHLETIC
TEAMS THAT THEY GET EXEMPTIONS
THAT THE SMALLER GUYS JUST DON'T
GET AND I JUST WONDER HOW LONG.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE. TO GIVE
A HAND OUT. TO THE ONE
PERCENTERS THE BIG CORPORATIONS
OUT THERE AT THE EXPENSE OF THE
SMALLER GUYS I THINK THERE IS A
WAY- TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
WITHOUT- YOU KNOW TRAMPLING. ON
THE SMALLER GUYS SO WITH THAT-
I'M SORRY I CAN'T SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY I APPRECIATE. WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO BUT I THINK
THERE'S- FAR TOO MANY- YOU KNOW
I'M I'M- ISSUE IN THIS BILL. FOR
US TO MOVE IT FOR IN THE HOPES.
THAT IT SOME POINT DOWN THE ROAD
A GETS PICKED YOU MANAGE. THANK
YOU SENATOR MILLER. SENATOR MEN-
QUESTION FOR THE OTHER. YES SO I
WANT TO MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND
THE SPEAR OF THE MEN THAT
YOU'RE- TODAY. IS A CORRECT THAT
YOU ARE. TO ADD THE CONCERNS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CINEMA REYES TO
IS THAT- THIS. YOUR WHICH MAY
STILL NEED TO BE FLESHED OUT A
LITTLE BIT. THE GOAL IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE NOT. PERMITTING
NEW ADVERTISING THAT IS IN
VIOLATION OF FEDERAL LAW THAT
ALL OF THE FEATHER ALL OF THE
NEW ADVERTISING AROUND SPORTS
ARENAS. THAT IS PERMITTED UNDER
YOUR BILL WOULD BE COMPLIANT
WITH FEDERAL LAW TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERN HE HAS IS THAT KIND OF
THE GOAL YOU DON'T IS THAT GONNA
BE CONTINUE TO BE THE GOAL
YOU'RE WORKING TOWARDS AS YOU
CONTINUE TAKING MINUTES. YES
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THANK
YOU AND SO I APPRECIATE THAT
ANSWER I THINK. THAT ADDRESSES
MY MAIN CONCERN WITH THIS BILL
SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY I HOPE YOU CONTINUE TO
WORK TO. A PERFECTED ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY
MY COLLEAGUES BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCHFOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR MEN
AND SENATE ARCHULETA YES I'M-
MANAGER EDWIN ADDITIONAL
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR. THE
EXPANSION. OF THESE NEW
BILLBOARDS WITH A GO BEYOND A
MILE AND A HALF. I THOUGHT THERE
WAS A- LIMIT. MY CONCERN IS TO
GO TO FAR. IN ENCROACH INTO. THE
OTHERS A SMALL- BILLBOARDS AND
SO ON. RIGHT I THOUGHT IT WAS
IT'S RIGHT. EXACTLY THE ARENA
AND THEY WOULD ONLY ADVERTISE.
THE PRODUCTS WITHIN THE ARENA.
OR IS THE BILL TAKEN IT. OUTSIDE
BEYOND. THAT SAY A MILE OR SO
IT'S IN THE PERIPHERY OF THE
ARENA. BUT NOT. EXCEEDING MAYBE
A THOUSAND FEET RIGHT THOUSAND
FEET IT DOESN'T EXCEED A
THOUSAND FEET YEAH. THANK YOU.
MANY THANK YOUS AND ARCHULETA
WILL GO BACK TO SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU I JUST WANNA
CLARIFICATION- WHAT MOM SENATOR
ARE TO LARGEST PASSED. IS IT A
THOUSAND FEET WITHIN THE ARENA I
CAN YOU CLARIFY THERE'S A POP UP
AND I'M SORRY I DON'T HAVE IN
FRONT OF ME RIGHT NOW WHERE IT
TALKS ABOUT A PARKING STRUCTURE
OR- PARKING FOR THE ARENA CAN
YOU CLARIFY IS IT FROM THE
STADIUM. OR FROM THE PARKING
IT'S FROM THE ANY PARKING
FACILITY USED IN THE OPERATION
OF THE ARENA. BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE I HAVE A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED ANY A PARKING USE IN
THE OPERATION OF THE ARENA SO
LET'S SAY POTENTIALLY THEY CAN.
BUY A SECOND LOT SOMEWHERE ELSE
TO ACCOMMODATE THE OVERFLOW
TRAFFIC AND- AND PARKING OF THE
ARENA DOES THAT MEAN THAT THEY
WILL USE THAT. TO QUALIFIED AS
ONE THOUSAND FEET SO IT COULD
BE. I DON'T KNOW LET'S SAY TWO
THREE BLOCKS AWAY FROM THE ARENA
CANNOT BE MISUSED IN ANYWAY WELL
WE TRIED OUR BEST A THOUSAND
FEET FROM ANY PARKING FACILITY
USED IN THE OPERATION OF THE
ARENA. WE TRIED TO MAKE IT AS
CLEAR AS POSSIBLE IT'S AT THE
ARENA PARKING FACILITY. AT THE
ARENA. OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR CORTESE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR OF I'M I'M SUPPORTIVE OF
THE BILL- IN I DO I DO HAVE ONE
CONCERN I WANT TO BRING OUT- I.
IT'S REALLY THE ONLY CONCERN I
HAVE OF FOR WHATEVER THAT'S
WORTH BUT- I'M NOT. VERY
SYMPATHETIC TO THE COMPETITION
ISSUE- ALSO HAVING BEEN A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL AND SEEN
SOME OF THE BATTLES TO. OF THE
INDUSTRY JUST TO TRY TO GET A
PRESENCE IN IN HIGH TRAFFIC HIGH
PROFILE AREAS I'M NOT SURE WHY
ANYBODY IN THIS INDUSTRY WOULD
OPPOSE SOMEBODY ELSE. BREAKING
THROUGH- TO CREATE OPPORTUNITY I
MEAN IT SEEMS TO BE AN INDUSTRY
THAT'S UNDER SIEGE AND YOU'D
THINK EVERYONE WOULD. JUMP
ABOARD SAY THE MORE THE MERRIER
WE LIKE THIS KIND OF COMPETITION
BECAUSE IT RE OPENS OUR
INDUSTRY- SO THAT IS MY THINKING
AGAIN I JUST. FELT LIKE SAYING
THAT- THANK YOU FOR INDULGING ME
IN THAT- BUT I WOULD SAY ON THE
HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION ISSUE
ALSO ALONG WITH SOME OF MY SOME
OF OUR COLLEAGUES HERE HAVING
SERVED. A LONG TIME- YOU KNOW
DEALING WITH THE FEDERAL DOT AND
HIGHWAY MINISTRATION SO FORTH I
THINK AT SOME POINT YOU NEED TO
GO FURTHER THAN THESE AMENDMENTS
ARE AT SUPPORT THIS TODAY. BUT
TO REALLY REQUIRE AN
AFFIRMATIVE. DOCUMENT OF SOME
KIND OF FROM HOW IT MINISTRATION
CONCURRENT WITH THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF- OF THESE NEW
BILLBOARDS I JUST DON'T TRUST
EIGHT WE SAW WITH CHANGES OF
ADMINISTRATION- OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS COMMITMENTS THAT WERE
MADE THAT WERE PULLED BACK IN.
VERBAL COMMITMENTS THAT WERE
MADE THAT WERE SOFTENED UP LATER
ON AND THINGS LIKE THAT SO-
AGES. WHAT I WOULD ENCOURAGE
INTO. ASSUMING THAT- WILL ALL
GET ANOTHER CHANCE TO VOTE ON
THIS BILL AT SOME POINT- THAT-
AND- YOU WOULD FEEL A LOT BETTER
TO ME. TO NOT JUST. KEEP MOVING
IF THERE'S NO OBJECTION BUT TO-
YOU KNOW TO REQUIRE- PROOF OF
THAT NON OBJECTION- FROM FROM
THE FEDS BEFORE PROCEEDING AND I
THINK THAT WOULD PROTECT
EVERYONE INVOLVED INCLUDING THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE INVESTING IN
THESE BILLBOARDS IN- AT AND
WOULD SUIT CAN ONLY ASSUME AT
SOME POINT- IT TURNS INTO- THE
LEGAL WORLD THAT THAT WOULDN'T
BE VERY PRETTY IF THAT HAPPENED
SO. SO YOU JUST WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR CONCERN BUT- AT. UNLIKE THE
BILL OVERALL AND- PRESHEAF THE
AUTHOR BRING FORTH THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR CORTESE WE
HAVE ONE LAST MIKE UP BY SENATOR
ALAN- YEAH I MEAN I LOOK AT.
I'VE I'VE 'M I'M HAVE I'M
WILLING THE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY TO GIVE YOU GOT THE
OPPORTUNITY CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THESE ISSUES BUT I WILL SAY THAT
. I THINK THEY'RE THEY'RE YOU
KNOW. I THINK THE FIRST MINUTE
USER ARE REAL- AND I THINK IF WE
WERE TO MAKE THE SIGN SMALLER
THAT WOULD HELP- I KNOW THAT
CALTRANS HAS BEEN IN THE MIDDLE
OF A BIG BATTLE OVER SIGNS IN
INGLEWOOD AND IT'S JUST IT'S A
BIG MASSIVE IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
AND- I THINK IT'S YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT THE ENFORCEMENT IS
GOING TO BE TOUGH. HI IN THIS
WERE REALLY SMART ABOUT AND I
WOULD ASK THAT THE AUTHOR-
REALLY SPENT SOME TIME DIGGING
INTO THAT ISSUE- INSURING I
THERE'S GOOD ENFORCEMENT AND
THAT THEY WERE ABLE TO RESPOND
QUICKLY IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TRIES TO CLAMP DOWN.
ON US BECAUSE I'M I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THE CERTAINLY STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND I AND BY THE
WAY I UNDERSTAND WE'VE BEEN
ACTING IN THIS MANNER FOR A LONG
TIME THIS BILL I'M JUST GOING TO
CONTINUE THE EXISTING PRACTICE
BUT I DO THINK AT SOME POINT
WE'VE GOT TO PUT IN PLACE
MECHANISMS THAT ARE GONNA ALLOW
US TO RESPOND QUICKLY. IF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DECIDES TO-
INFOWARS- THEIR THEIR RULES AND
I DON'T THINK IT'S OUT OF THE
REALM OF POSSIBILITY SO I JUST
WOULD ASK THAT THE CHAIR IN THE
AUTHOR AND OTHERS- WORK ON ON ON
REALLY TRYING TO TIGHTEN UP AND
ENSURE FOR BETTER ENFORCEMENT
BECAUSE I DO THINK THERE'S- I
THINK I THINK THIS IS THIS JUST
CAN DOUBLE DOWN ON THE RISK THAT
WERE ALREADY TAKING AT THE
STATE. THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN
AND ALL JUST CONCLUDE WITH
SAYING- YOU KNOW THE THIS IS
BEEN A LONG DEBATED BETWEEN BOTH
SIDES MIGHT- COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT AND OUR TEAM HAD
WORKED WITH THE AUTHORED BOTH
SIDES TO ENSURE THAT THERE WAS.
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD WITHOUT WAS EMPTY AND-
AMENABLE TO BOTH SIDES OF IN THE
TIME BEING KNOWING THAT WE WOULD
STILL NEGOTIATE FORWARD- SO
AGAIN I. RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
BRING THIS BACK IF THERE'S
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES AND WE CAN
CONTINUE TO DEBATE. IF THERE'S
CHANGES THAT. ARE AMENABLE
MOVING FORWARD OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE- BUT YOU BRING GOOD
POINTS OF I THINK EVERYBODY'S
ABOUT GREAT COMMENTS AND GREAT
POINTS UP AND SO I THINK- AT
THIS TIME I KNOW AND I HAVE
TRUST THAT THE AUTHORS WILL WORK
WITH BOTH SIDES TO CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION MOVING FORWARD. AND I
PERSONALLY HEARD FROM MY LOCAL-
YOU KNOW SMALLER BILLBOARD-
FOLKS BACK AT HOME AND I'M YOU
KNOW VERY. CONSCIOUS OF WHAT
THEY'RE- ISSUES ARE AND I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ADDRESS
THOSE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE. WITH
THAT I DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER
MIKES UP WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR ARCH META. IS THAT
CORRECT- IF I MADE ONE MORE JUST
JUST TO CLARIFY. BECAUSE I
STARTED OFF ABOUT A KNOWLEDGE IN
THE FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND THE COMPLIANCE WITHIN- ARE
WE ASKING THAT OR- PROBABLY
INDICATING THAT BILLBOARDS IT
WILL BE CONSTRUCTED WILL EXCEED.
THE. AND IF THEY'RE NOT CAUGHT.
THEN IT WILL CONTINUE OR'S THIS
INDICATING THAT ANY BILLBOARDS
THAT ARE CONSTRUCTED WILL
MAINTAIN THE SIZE THAT'S WITHIN
CALIFORNIA STANDARDS. WE ARE WE
TRYING TO MAKE AN EXEMPTION ON
THEIR SITES AS WELL. I DON'T
KNOW WHAT WITH REGARDS TO THE
SIZE RIGHT NOTE THE ISSUE HERE
IS ABOUT CONTINUING THE
EXEMPTION WITH THE CONDITIONS
THAT THEY HAVE- AND- YOU KNOW
EXPAND THE NET TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY COULD HAVE THE SIGNS WITHIN
THE THOUSAND FEET WHICH IS WHAT
YOU YOU TALKED ABOUT AND ADDING
LANGUAGE WHICH MAKES UP A GIVES
CALTRANS MUCH MORE POWER AND
MUCH MORE STRENGTH. TO ENFORCE
ANY SIGN OR OPPOSE ANY SIGN OR
TAKE DOWN ANY SIGN THAT COULD
THREATEN OUR FEDERAL FUNDING SO
THAT'S THOSE WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE ADDED TO THE EXEMPTION
THAT ALREADY EXIST. AND YOUR- A
BID MARKET GOES BACK TO MY
QUESTION SO IF THEY CONSTRUCTED
SIGN THAT EXCEEDS THE REQUIRED.
LIMITATIONS THAT'S GONNA BE OKAY
NO BY DID- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T. TAKE IT DOWN
WELL AGAIN THERE ARE LOCALLY
SHOULD EVEN BE CONSTRUCTED RIGHT
SEEDING THE LIMITATIONS WHATEVER
THE LOCAL RULES ARE THAT'S THE
FIRST THING THEY HAVE TO HAVE
APPROVAL FROM THE LOCAL RULES
BECAUSE THERE ARE LOCAL RULES
LIKE IT'S NOT JUST FEDERAL RULES
ARE LOCAL RULES THAT THEY ABIDE
BY. THERE'S A STATE AND AS THE
FEDERAL SO THE STATE WE'RE
SAYING IS GOING TO HAVE MUCH
MORE POWER TO ENFORCE ESPECIALLY
THE CONCERN RAISED BY MY
COLLEAGUES HERE AT OTHERS
ESPECIALLY THE CONCERN ABOUT THE
THREAT TO LOSING FEDERAL HIGHWAY
FUNDS SO ANYTHING THAT THREATENS
THAT BUT IT'S NOT JUST THE
ORDINANCES THAT THEY HAVE TO
RESPECT. I AGAIN I'VE GOT IT.
SENATE ARCHULETA IF WE CAN YEAH
I KNOW I WHEN I WENT OUT THERE
ARE YOU GOING OF FIVE A LOT OF
CONVERSE. YET TO TAKE PLACE
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU SAID
ARCHULETA AND WE HAVE ONE LAST
QUESTION I'M I'M- AND I'M SO
SORRY MADAM CHAIR AT YOU KNOW-
MY COLLEAGUE REOPEN THE
DISCUSSION BUT I DO WANT TO ASK
YOU DIRECTLY- SENATOR. I'M DON'T
YOU THINK THAT THE THAT THE
FOLKS WHO WERE BENEFITING FROM
THIS BILL. I TO FIGURE OUT DO WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT SOME
COMPENSATION SCHEME FOR THE
STATE. TO FOR THAT FOR THE RISK
THAT WE'RE TAKING ON. BY
ALLOWING FOR THE SYSTEM TO
CONTINUE AND GROW. SOME SORT OF
TAX OR ROYALTY. AT AT AT THIS
POINT YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT THAT
WASN'T THE POINT OF THIS BILL SO
I'M NOT PREPARED TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT
WE ASK THAT OF ANY INDUSTRY IS
THAT IF THERE IS A POTENTIAL
THREAT OR POTENTIAL VIOLATION IT
IS NOT FREQUENT THAT WE PASS.
LAWS EXECUTIVE BASICALLY
DOUBLING DOWN ON FEDERAL LAW
VIOLATIONS. WELL WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT I DON'T AGREE THAT WE'RE
DOUBLING DOWN ON FEDERAL LAW
VIOLATIONS WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
IS- THERE WILL BE MORE
BILLBOARDS THAT ARE PUT UP IN
THESE ARENAS. THAT IS NOT EQUAL
TO DOUBLING DOWN ON A FEDERAL-
VIOLATIONS I DON'T I DON'T SEE
THE CONNECTION THERE'S NOT A
CORRECT. A CLEAR CONNECTION
THERE JUST BECAUSE MORE
BILLBOARDS ARE GOING THIS IS A
VIOLATION OF THE LADY BIRD
JOHNSON ACT I MEAN THAT THE WHAT
IS THIS THIS THIS THIS ACTIVITY.
THIS YEAR THE THIS OF THIS TYPE
OF APPROVAL OF SCIENCE. ON OUR
HIGHWAYS. CENTER ALLEN ARE YOU
ARE YOU FINISHED WITH YOUR LINE
OF QUESTIONING IS YOU'RE ASKING
THE SAME QUESTIONS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO GET IT
ADDRESS BUT THAT WE ARE VERY
CLEAR IN WHAT THE BILL STATES.
IT DOESN'T DISCUSS ANY
COMPENSATION WHICH MAY BE A GOOD
IDEA BUT WE WELL OKAY THEN I
GUESS I WOULD JUST LIKE TO BE
CONSIDERED AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD BECAUSE I DO THINK- I
THINK WE'RE TAKING ON A RISK
HERE I UNDERSTAND THAT WE'VE
NEVER BEEN THREATENED- WITH WITH
THE WITHHOLDING OF FEDERAL FUNDS
BUT WE KNOW THAT THIS IS A RISK.
AND I THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE
BAKED INTO OUR WORK IN THIS
SPACE AS WE MOVE FORWARD. OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATORS I
APPRECIATE THE DEBATE ONCE
AGAIN- WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR ARCHER LET I BELIEVE.
WHO MOVED THE BILL. MISTER CHIEF
CONSERVE OUR US SENATOR DORADO I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN. DISCUSSED THIS
IS THIS ISSUE WITH. ALL THE
MEMBERS BUT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. YES I APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S COMMENTS. AND I
APPRECIATE THE NEW IDEAS THAT
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT FORWARD TO ME.
AND I ASSURE YOU WE'RE GOING TO
GO BACK AND DISCUSS THEM.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS- AND I HEAR YOU LOUD
AND CLEAR ESPECIALLY WITH
REGARDS TO. ANY THREAT. TO OUR
FEDERAL FUNDING SO THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH AND I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHIE
WILL US SENATOR DO RUSSELL AGAIN
MOTION BY SENATOR ARCHULETA
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED AND BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ HI BATES H.
NOW ALLEN ALLEN I WHAT'S A
LETTER ARCHULETA HI BAKER.
CORTESE CORTESE I DALY DOLLY NO
DOT DODD HI LIMON. MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ MELINDA'S NOW. MANY
NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE RUBIO. SKINNER
MY COUNTY MY COUNTY I WILL. OKAY
SEVENTY THREE AT THIS TIME WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
SENATOR GRASSO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE SENATOR
GLAZER WHO'S BEEN VERY PATIENTLY
WAITING- WILL ASK HIM TO COME UP
TO ACTUAL SENATOR GLAZERS WILL
ASK YOU TO COME UP TO THIS
PODIUM HERE BECAUSE THERE'S ONLY
ONE CAMERA- IT THAT BUSH WILL
SHOOT. IN THE FRONT HERE. OKAY
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND BEFORE YOU
GET STARTED WILL DO CONSENT
REALLY QUICKLY- BECAUSE WE HAVE
A SALAS REQUIREMENT I KNOW
MEMBERS ARE COMING IN AND
OUTSIDE COLLEGE EYES. OF MEMBERS
AGAIN ITEM TEN SB TWELVE A ONE
BY SENATOR MELISSA MELENDEZ HAS
BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. OF
THE WE HAVE A CONSENT CALENDAR
CONSISTING OF THE FOLLOWING
ITEMS ITEM ONE THREE FOUR SIX
EIGHT NINE AND FIFTEEN- CAN WE
GET A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR PLEASE SENATOR DOLLY.
THANK YOU. AND MR XI CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CONSENT
CALENDAR NUMBER ONE CONSISTING
OF S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE SB
ELEVEN NINETY THREE AND S. B.
THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT. SENATORS
GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ I BATES.
BATES AYE ALLEN. ALLEN I PARTULA
ARCHULETA I BAKER CORTESE
CORTESE I. DALI. DOLLY I DOT.
LIMON MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
AYE MIN. NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE RUBIO
RUBIO AYE SKINNER MY COUNTY MY
CASKEY I WILL. OKAY WE HAVE TEN
VOTES I FOR CONSENT CALENDARS
THAT IS PASSED BUT WE'LL PUT
THAT ON A CALL AS WELL AND
CONTENT CALENDAR TO WILL BE FOR
HI WE NAMING RESOLUTIONS AS
WE'VE DONE BEFORE- WITH TO
CONSENT CALENDARS BUT YOU MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE
QUICKLY CALL THE ROLL AND
CONSENT- ITEM NUMBER TWO.
CONSENT CALENDAR TWO CONSISTING
OF S. C. R. SEVENTY FIVE AS C.
R. SEVENTY EIGHT AND S. C. R.
SIXTY EIGHT CENTERS GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ I. BATES BATES AYE
ALLEN. ELLEN I ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA HI BAKER- DAISY
CORTESE I DOLLY DALY HI DOT.
LIMON MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MELINDA'S
I MAN. NEWMAN NEWMAN I RUBIO.
RUBIO I SKINNER WHITE HOUSE K.
Y. CASKEY I WILL. TEN AND
CONTENT CALENDAR TO LEAVE THAT
ON CALL THANK YOU WELCOME
SENATOR GLAZERS PLEASE PRESENT
ON SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THANK YOU- ADAM SURE
NEITHER PEACEFUL MORNING HERE IN
THE CAPITAL IT'S GREAT TO BE
WITH YOU- SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT TODAY FIRST LET ME
THANK THE STAFF AT THE CHAIR FOR
WORKING ON THIS BILL AND FOR
THEIR EXCELLENT ANALYSIS. THE
BILL WOULD CLARIFY AND EXPAND
THE AUTHORITY OF PARTS INSPECTOR
GENERAL. AND GIVE THE OFFICE
MORE PROTECTION FROM IMPROPER
INTERFERENCE IN ITS WORK. BAY
AREA VOTERS CREATED THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. AS A PART OF
A BALLOT MEASURE THAT ALSO GAVE
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITIES THE POWER TO RAISE
BRIDGE TOLLS TO FINANCE
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT OFFICE. GIVES
THE PUBLIC AND SYSTEM RIDERS
INDEPENDENT SET OF EYES AND
EARS. TO MONITOR THE AGENCY
SPENDING AND OPERATIONS. WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH FORMER STATE
AUDITOR ELAINE HOWLE TWO
RESEARCH AND CRAFT THIS BILL.
AND MOST OF WHAT ARE WE ARE
PROPOSING IS ALREADY BEING DONE
BY THE STATE AUDITOR THE
CALTRANS INSPECTOR GENERAL FOR
THE LOS ANGELES METRO INSPECTOR
GENERAL. MS HOW SUPPORTS THE
BILL AS TO THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF INSPECTOR
GENERALS IN THE ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AUDITORS. ALL
THESE FOLKS SUPPORT THE BILL
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THE BART
INSPECTOR GENERAL NEEDS THESE
CHANGES. TO BE ABLE TO FULFILL
THE MISSION THIS LEGISLATURE AND
THE VOTERS ASK THEM TO DO. THE
BILL CLARIFIES THAT THE OFFICE
SHOULD HAVE THE INDEPENDENCE TO
CONDUCT ITS WORK. IN CONFORMITY
WITH GOVERNMENT AUDITING
STANDARDS. PUBLISHED BY THE CAN
COMPTROLLER GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES. AND WITH THE
PRINCIPLES AND STANDARDS FOR
OFFICES OF INSPECTOR GENERAL.
PUBLISHED BY THE ASSOCIATION OF
INSPECTOR GENERALS. SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL GIVES THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL ACCESS TO AGENCY
DOCUMENTS AND THE RIGHT TO
INTERVIEW EMPLOYEES. IT ALSO
GIVES THE OFFICE THE ABILITY TO
HIRE STAFF PROTECT CONFIDENTIAL
COMPUTER FILES FROM IMPROPER
DISCLOSURE. AND FINALLY THE BILL
ALSO RAISES THE BAR FOR FIRING
AN INSPECTOR GENERAL DURING
THEIR FOUR YEAR TERM. ENSURING
THAT THEY WILL ONLY BE DISMISSED
FOR MALFEASANCE AND NOT BECAUSE
THEIR WORK IS AN IRRITANT OR
EMBARRASSING TO THE STAFF OR THE
BOARD OF THE AGENCY. WITH ME IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL R. LIZ AIMS
A MEMBER OF THE BART BOARD OF
DIRECTORS. AND DAVID MCCLINTOCK
CHAIR OF THE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS COMMITTEE OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF INSPECTOR
GENERALS ALSO ON THE LINE IS
HARRIET RICHARDS IN THE BART
INSPECTOR GENERAL IN CASE YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT HER
WORK OR OPERATIONS THANK YOU
MEDICARE THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZERS. I WILL START WITH- MISS
AMES ON THE COASTLINE- THE BART
BOARD OF DIRECTORS MEMBER.
MODERATOR TO HAVE MISSED AIMS ON
THE LINE. I DO NOT SEE HER NAME
BUT ADMITS AIMS YOU ONLINE YOU
MAY PRESS STAR ZERO. I DO NOT
SEE HER QUEUING UP ATTHAT TIME
OKAY MODERATOR WILL GO TO-
MISTER DAVID MCCLINTOCK
ASSOCIATION OF INSPECTORS
GENERAL. ON THE LINE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY YEAH THE OPENING
DAY MCCLINTOCK AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE ASSOCIATION
INSPECTOR GENERAL THE
ASSOCIATION INSPECTOR GENERAL IS
AN INDEPENDENT NONPARTISAN
FATHER ONE THREE THREE WE ARE
THE LARGESTORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING INSPECTORS GENERAL
NATIONALLY. WE REPRESENT
HUNDREDS OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
OFFICES ARE HUNDREDS OF
INSPECTORS GENERAL STAFF AND
OFFICES ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
AND INTERNATIONAL. MISTER
MCCLINTOCK. YES MA'AM I GOT
SOMEBODY ELSE FROM THE IN MY EAR
HOW THAT'S GOING TO HAVE
SOMEBODY SOMEBODY ELSE IN MY
EAR- ONE AT THE FOURTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT- PROPOSED BILL TO AMEND
THE LEGISLATION RELATED TO THE
STORY THERE YOUR APP TRANSIT. IN
THE OFFICE OF ISPECTOR GENERAL
ARGUED THAT THE FOURTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT INDICATE THAT IT IS WHOLLY
CONSISTENT WITH THE A. I. T.'S
ESTABLISHED 'NCIPLES
STANDARDS FOR OFFICES INSPECTOR
INDIA. THIS IS THE PREDOMINANT-
METRIC OF PRINCIPLES AND
STANDARDS. ACROSS THE NATION FOR
STATE AND LOCAL INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S IT IS THE STANDARD BY
WHICH WE- PROVIDE PEER REVIEW OF
INSPECTORS GENERAL- NATIONALLY
AND INTERNATIONALLY. THERE'S
BROAD CONSENSUS WITHIN THE O. I.
G. COMMUNITIES THE ELEMENT OF
THIS BILL ARE COMMON PRACTICES
WITHIN THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
ENVIRONMENT. WE BELIEVE IT'LL
SUBSTANTIALLY IMPROVE THE
INDEPENDENCE OF THE BARCODE YG.
I. STABBINGS AND CLARIFYING THE
PROCESS FOR THE APPOINTMENT AND
REMOVAL OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL. HIRING EVALUATION
RETENTION OF THE- I. T. STAFF
AND CONSULTANTS. THE REFINEMENT
OF DUTIES AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
HE ACCESS TO RECORDS PROPERTY
EMPLOYEES. OFFICERS AND
CONTRACTORS SUBPOENA AUTHORITY.
ALSO THE REQUIREMENT OF BART'S
RESPONSE TO- IG RECOMMENDATIONS
IN THE ESTABLISHMENT OF SYSTEMS
AND RECORDS THAT ARE INDEPENDENT
FROM THOSE MAINTAINED BY PART.
SO IMPLEMENTED IN VARIOUS
MANNERS FROM OFFICE TO OFFICE
THE OPERATIONAL PROTOCOLS ARE
DESIGNED TO ENSURE ONE THING
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE THAT IS
THE INDEPENDENCE OF THE OFFICE
OF INSPECTOR GENERAL. WITHOUT
INDEPENDENCE WE OFTEN END UP
WITH THE APPEARANCES OF
OVERSIGHT WITHOUT THE
PRACTICALITY OF OVERSIGHT. THE
AG PRODUCTIONS IN THE EVENT THAT
IF THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION OR CONVERSATION
DESIRED THE ENERGY. THE DEATH OF
AN EXPERTISE IN NAVIGATING
COMPLEX ISSUES. AND WILL
CONTINUE TO ACT IN A NONPARTISAN
NONPROFIT IN A NONPARTISAN
FASHION TO SUPPORT THE MOVEMENT
OF THIS BILL AS THE LEGISLATURE
MAY SEE FIT RESPECTFULLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY THANK YOU
MISTER MCCLINTOCK WE APPRECIATE
THAT- MODERATOR WE DO HAVE MS
ELIZABETH AMES- ON LEAD WITNESS
IN SUPPORT TO ISSUE BACK ON THE
LINE. MODERATOR DO WE HAVE MISS
AMES ON THE LINE. THE LAST ONE
MORE TIME MODERATOR TO HIM SHE-
DO WE HAVE A LIST AIMS AT
DOCUMENTED OKAY THANK YOU MS
NAMES YOU MAY PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER. THIS IS LIZ
AMOS ONE OF NINE MEMBERS OF THE
BART DIRECTORS AND I SUPPORT
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. AS A LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CIVIL ENGINEER AND
AS A FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
PALO ALTO COMMUNITY FEDERAL
CREDIT UNION. I REALIZE HOW
CRITICAL IT WAS TO ALLOW
COMPLETE ACCESS TO EVERY EMAIL
AND FILE AT THE CREDIT UNION BY
FEDERAL AUDITORS. AND CITY
AUDITORS TO DO THE SAME FOR A
PERFORMANCE AUDIT OF THE STREET
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM I MANAGED.
PART OF NEVER EXPERIENCED
ARTISTS WHERE THEY HAVE TO ALLOW
ALL FILES AND EMAILS. TO BE
DISCLOSED FOR EVALUATION OF
THEIR PERFORMANCE ON PROGRAMS
AND POLICIES. THE ODYSSEY
RECEIVE PRIMARILY FOCUS ON
EXPENDITURES BUT NOT ON HOW
INVESTMENTS ARE CHOSEN AND
PROJECTS ARE MANAGED. BACKSTAIRS
DESERVES STRONG OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN ORDER TO TRUST
IN PART. WITH SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT PART WILL BE EXPECTED TO
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION TO
JUSTIFY THEIR BUDGETS AND
PROJECT DETAILS THE FORK
SENATORS ARE MADE ON MULTI
MILLION DOLLAR CONTRACTS. ARCH
HAS A COMBINED ANNUAL OPERATING
AND CAPITAL BUDGET OF TWO POINT
FIVE BILLION. THE PUBLIC DEMAND
TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT AND
WANTS TO KNOW HOW BURKE SPEND
OUR TAX DOLLARS. THE BEST WAY TO
IMPROVE THE PUBLIC'S TRUST AND
TRANSPARENCY IS BY HAVING
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT WITHOUT
INTERFERENCE. BUT THREE YEARS
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S OFFICE. I
THINK COUNTER NUMBERS CHALLENGES
IN ITS ABILITY TO PERFORM THE
WORK BUT THE INDEPENDENT
EXPECTED OF AN INSPECTOR GENERAL
AS DESCRIBED IN THE BILL AND
ALICE'S. I ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO
PASS THIS LEGISLATION TO ENSURE
THAT PARK IS NOT EXTRACT THE
OFFICE OF THE PARK INSPECTOR
GENERAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS AIMS TO HAVE CONCLUDED LEAD
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT SO WE'LL
TAKE IT TO THE GALLERY ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
PLEASE. C. NONE MODERATOR WILL
TAKE IT BACK TO YOU FOR ANYONE
IN THE QUEUE WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
A SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE. THANK YOU AND IF
YOU ARE A PART OF FOURTEEN F. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS THE ONE AND THEN ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. WE DO
HAVE A FEW KEY ONE UP ONE MOMENT
PLEASE FOR THE GIVEN THAT MY
NUMBER. I'M NEXT REPORT LINE-
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
COURTNEY MARIE AND I WERE SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND THAT WE WILL GO
TO LINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS MARIE HOGAN AND I
REPRESENT THE ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AUDITORS.
FIFTEEN OR ADVOCATE THE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR CALIFORNIA
AND THE ON THE- FORMER ELECTED
CITY AUDITOR FOR THE CITY OF
BERKELEY AND I SUPPORT SB ONE
FOUR EIGHT EIGHT OUT OF THE
COURT. THANK YOU. ONE FOUR EIGHT
EIGHT. IT WILL NOT TELL NINE
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME CHEN MEMBERS MY NAME'S
PRODUCT BRAND I MEAN YOU KIND OF
THEY- I SPEAK IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN
EXTRA VOTE TO LINE SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JORGE WAS THE
GERA I AM THE CITY AUDITOR FOR
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO. AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF AT B. ONE FOUR
EIGHT EIGHT. THANK YOU AN EXTRA
BOTTLE LINE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
AND- DEBORAH ALLEN EIGHT CAREER
FINANCE PROFESSIONAL CPA AND A
BOARD DIRECTOR FOR SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT AND I
SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
. THANK YOU AND A COUPLE TO LINE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
TWELVE YEAR LINE IS OPENED YOU
HAVE A TIME YOU. AND I'M SURE WE
HAVE NO FOR THIS IMPORTANT YOU
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MODERATOR- NOW WILL TAKE IT TO
LEAD OPPOSITION- WE HAVE
TESTIMONY BY ONE PERSON MISTER
MARK FOLEY- BART BOARD OF
DIRECTORS ON THE CO HOST LINE
SO. MODERATOR CAN WE TURN TO
OPPOSITION FOR SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT MISTER MARK FOLEY
IS ON THE LINE. GOOD MORNING
CHILDREN'S ALL OF THE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MARK PHONE ITEM NUMBER
OF PART FORTY DIRECTORS AND
IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
BOARD. BOB SUPPORTED THE
CREATION OF THE PARTS BACK TO
GENERAL AND WE AGREE WITH.
SENATOR GLAZERS THAT THIS
PARTICULAR POSITION PARTISAN
VITAL ROLE IN PROVIDING
OVERSIGHT BOARDS FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT. OPERATIONAL
EFFECTIVENESS AND REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE. HOWEVER LAST WEEK
THE BORDER BORDER DUE TO TAKING
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON XP FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
GIVEN OUR CONCERNS WITH THE BILL
IT'S CURRENTLY RIGHT. FIRST VICE
STANDARDS FOR REMOVAL OF THE IG
ART FORM MORE STRINGENT. THAN
ANY OTHER STATE OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT I G. WE'VE STARTED.
THE EXPANDED SCOPE OF THE OFFICE
TO INVESTIGATE ALLEGED FRAUD
WASTE AND ABUSE COULD ALSO BE
INTERPRETED TO INTERFERE WITH
THE WORK IN THE POSITION
OVERSIGHT BODIES APART. SUCH AS
OFFICE OF THE INDEPENDENT POLICE
AUDITOR. SHOULD WE WILL GRAB THE
IG. ACCESS TO ALL DISTRICT
RECORDS IMPROPER. THERE WERE NO
PROVISIONS TO RESTRICT THE
OFFICE ACCESS TO CONFIDENTIAL
RECORDS WHAT PRIVILEGED
INFORMATION WHICH CAN CREATE
POTENTIAL CONFLICTS WITH
EXISTING OVER SEVENTY FEET APART
. IT IS WATER PRIORITY TO
FACILITY PRODUCTIVE
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN THE IG AND
OUR LABOR PART. B. I G. DOCTORS
TO IMPORTANCE CAN BE IMPROVED IF
THEY RECOGNIZED ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVE PLEASE. UNDER THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT.
IT BILL FURTHER FOR GENTLEMEN
RESPOND TO THE I. G. WITHIN TEN
DAYS OF THE OFFICE MAKING A FINE
ADRIN T. I. G. SOLD FORTY TO
ACCESS D. AT THE ADEQUACY OF THE
GM'S. CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS
WITH UNDERMINE BOARDS CURRENT
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE BY ALLOWING
SOMEONE OTHER THAN THE BOARD TO
DIRECTED BY. THE WAY TO LOOK AT
THE GENERAL MANAGER. FINALLY
BARCLAYS THE HIGH PRIORITY ON
THE- EQUITY AND INCLUSION IS AN
EXEMPLARY AND CONTRACTING. HE I
THINK HE SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED
TO POINTS THAT AND I PUBLIC
OFFICE SHOULD BE REQUIRED TO
COMPLY WITH ALL APPLICABLE
HIRING AND PROCUREMENT POLICY.
BOB WAS NOT CONSULTED DURING THE
DRAFTING OF THIS BILL HOWEVER WE
ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AND THE BOTTOM BACK
TO GENERAL. MAD MAX MOVIE FOR.
THROUGH PRODUCTIVE DIALOGUE WE
HOPE TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
AND EVEN SUPPORTED THIS BILL. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE HAVE
AVAILABLE ON THE PHONE ROBIN
BUCKSON ASSISTANT GENERAL
MANAGER OF EXTERNAL AFFAIRS TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR FOLEY SO
WE'VE CONCLUDED OUR LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT SO WE'LL
TAKE IT TO THE GALLERY FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT SEE NON MODERATOR
WILL TAKE IT BACK TO YOU TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE ANYONE IN Q.
WOULD LIKE TO. OPPOSE SB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. IF YOU'RE
NOT. ENOUGH SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE TIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SHANE GUSMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE BOARD OF THE
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION
REPRESENTS EMPLOYEES AT BARK- IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. YEAH MAN
I'M SURE WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU ARE SO WE'VE CONCLUDED
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION SO WE'LL
TAKE THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS BY MEMBERS. OKAY- SEE
NON- SENATOR GLAZERS I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK I
KNOW- YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS FOR AWHILE BUT I KNOW
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR
YOU KNOW PARTNERS IN LABOR AS
WELL AND- MANY STAKEHOLDERS IN
YOUR COMMUNITY SO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MEMBERS- AS
I'VE NOTED MY OPENING NOTHING IN
THIS BILL IS PARTICULARLY
UNUSUAL IN TERMS OF SETTING THE
SAME STANDARDS THAT PRACTICES
THAT WE HAVE FOR OUR CALTRANS
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND FOR OTHERS
IN THE STATE TO APPLY TO PART-
WE WANT TO HAVE A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE- IN OUR TRANSIT
AGENCIES ARE SO IMPORTANT THE
WORK THAT THEY DO. AND I THINK
THIS BILL WILL ENHANCE THAT AND
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT
BUT- THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZER
HOW DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT SENATOR
DODD THANK YOU. MISTER SHE
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. A SENATORS GONZALEZ
HI GONZALEZ HI BATES. BATES AYE
ALLEN. WHAT'S A LETTER. BAKER
CORTESE. DOLLY DOLLY HI BUT.
DADABHAI THE MON MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
I. MELENDEZ MEN. NEWMAN RUBIO.
RUBIO HI SKINNER MICHALSKI WHY
CASKEY AYE WILK. SEVEN ZERO WILL
KEEP THE UP CALL WE KEEP THE
FILE ITEM ON CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR GLAZERS ARSENAL
NEXT I WILL GO AHEAD AND PRESENT
OUT- PROVIDE THE GAVEL OFF TO MY
VICE CHAIR SENATOR BATES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
TENT THERE WE GO HERE SENATOR
GONZALEZ BEFORE YOU PRESENT YOUR
FIRST BILL I'D LIKE TO REMIND
THE PUBLIC OF THE PHONE NUMBERS
TO CALL IN AND TESTIFY FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OF THE PROJECT
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE ON THE LINK TO
TODAY'S HEARING. AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT THE PARTICIPANT
NUMBERS HEROES. 844-291-4185
ACCESS CODE. FOUR SIX SIX THREE
NINE SIX EIGHT. SENATOR GONZALEZ
YOU MAY NOW PRESENT YOUR FIRST
BILL AND I BELIEVE THAT'S SB
ELEVEN OH FOUR YES THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT S. B. ELEVEN OH FOUR
WHICH WILL ADVANCE THE
COORDINATION AND ECONOMIC
VITALITY OF THE FREIGHT SECTOR
OF THE FRACAS SECTOR AS WE KNOW
DRIVES ONE THIRD OF THE
CALIPHATE CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
CREATING MILLIONS OF JOBS AND
MOVING TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
GOODS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
HOWEVER THAT RECENT SUPPLY CHAIN
CRISIS HAS MADE IT CLEAR THAT
COMPLEX RIGHT SECTOR SYSTEMS.
THE BETTER HIGH LEVEL
COORDINATION A CLEAR EXAMPLE OF
THE CAL LOT LOSSES IN CALIFORNIA
INCURRED A BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
FREE ECHO ECONOMIC PLANNING IS
THAT WE ARE MISSING OUT ON
FEDERAL DOLLARS WEST COAST PORTS
SPECIFICALLY HAVE RECEIVED ONLY
ABOUT 10% OF THE FEDERAL DOLLARS
FOR PORT INFRASTRUCTURE WHEN
COMPARED TO THE DOLLARS
ALLOCATED TO EASTERN GULF COAST.
S. B. ELEVEN OH FOUR ADDRESSES
THIS GAP IN PLANNING BY CREATING
AN OFFICE UPGRADE WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IT WILL
FACILITATE CONCORD NATION FOR
THE MANY STAKEHOLDERS ALONG THE
SUPPLY SUPPLY CHAIN EXCUSE ME
AND CONDUCT A RECURRING
ASSESSMENT TO PLAN FOR THE
ECONOMIC COMPETITIVENESS OF THE
FREIGHT SECTOR TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY HAVE
MARTHA MILLER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PORT AUTHORITIES AND
JASON SMELSER. REPRESENTING THE
PACIFIC MARITIME SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION THINKING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ON AYE VOTE. ON S. B. ELEVEN OH
FOUR. THANK YOU SENATOR. WILL
START WITH THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES- ON THERE ARE THEY
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS KNOW THEIR-
TELECONFERENCE ALL START WITH ON
THIS MILLER. ARE YOU ON THE LINE. I DO NOT SEE HER AS OF YET.
THE LITTLE FOR A MOVE TO OUR
SECOND PRIMARY WITNESS WHO'S ON
MY COULD JACOB WITH PACIFIC
MERCHANT SHIPPING ASSOCIATION
MISTER JACOB ARE YOU ON THE LINE. FOR JASON SCHMELZER. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HERE. I DO NOT SEE
GRAYSON. MMHM I KNOW ARE YOU ON
THE LINE WE'RE IN THE GALLERY
SORRY MR JACOB. YES- PLEASE GO
AHEAD APOLOGIES- MANAGER
REMEMBERS THE- THE CALL IN LINE
WASN'T WORKING SO I RAN OVER
HERE FROM THE SAME SWING SPACE A
LITTLE BIT RECKLESS. I WILL GIVE
YOU TIME TO CATCH YOUR BREATH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR EMBERS AT
JASON SMELTER HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION AT PMSA REPRIMAND
REPRESENTS. THE MARINE TERMINAL
OPERATORS AND OCEAN GOING
VESSELS DOING BUSINESS A
CALIFORNIA'S PORTS WE ARE THE
PORT TENANTS. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE CREATION OF THE
OFFICE OF OPERATE I WOULD THINK
OF IS- AND THINK THE ELEVATION
OF SUPPLY CHAIN GOODS MOVEMENT
ISSUES WITHIN GOES GO VISIT IS
MUCH NEEDED. I WAS CLEAR ABOUT
THE CURRENT CRISIS IS THAT
THERE'S AN ASSORTMENT OF
DISTINCT CHALLENGES ACROSS THE
SUPPLY CHAIN THAT ARE WORKING
COLLECTIVELY TO CREATE A CRISIS.
IT'S ALSO CLEAR THAT THE SUPPLY
CHAIN IS OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE
TO ALL CALIFORNIANS AND HAVING
AN OFFICE OF FREE FOCUSED
EXCLUSIVELY ON THE FREIGHT
SECTOR WOULD BE BENEFICIAL UNDER
THESE CIRCUMSTANCES. WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE REQUIREMENT TO
PREPARE AN ASSESSMENT OF THE
COMPETITIVENESS GROWTH
RESILIENCY AND SUSTAINABILITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S RATES FOR- SECTOR-
THE CALIFORNIA'S FREED INDUSTRY-
IS OF SUFFICIENT CONSEQUENCE TO
THE STATE'S ECONOMIC HEALTH
OVERALL. ARE THAT IT WARRANTS
THIS THIS SORT OF ROUTINE-
EXAMINATION THAT'S PROPOSED BY
THE BILL AGAIN THANK YOU WHEN I
THINK THE- AUTHOR- AND HER
STAFF- MY CO SPONSOR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME. AND
APOLOGIZE FOR THE CONFUSION.
THANK YOU MISTER JACOB- LET'S
TRIED. A BACK CONCEIVED MISS
MILLER. IF PERHAPS ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. THANK YOU
MISTER MILLER IF YOU ARE ONLINE
YOU MAY PRESS. STAR. ZERO
EN ROUTE WE HAVE AN ENORMOUS
MILLER ON THE LINE THE END NOW
LET'S MOVE TO ANY WITNESSES ARE
IN SUPPORT WHO MIGHT BE HERE IN
THE CHAMBER AND GALLERY ANYONE
STEPPING FORWARD I DON'T SEE ANY
MODERATOR WERE YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE SO CALLED PEOPLE WHO
WISH TO SUPPORT SB ELEVEN OH
FOUR. THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF SB ELEVEN OH FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT ONE AND THEN ZERO FEAR IN
SUPPORT OF F. B. O. LET ME KNOW
FOR. BILBO LINE TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOU WHY TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING CARE NUMBERS NEXT CHAPPY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
. HI CAN YOU SORRY CAN I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU CAN HEAR ME. I'M YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU. THEY'RE CALLING
MY NAME AND I CAN CAN ACTIVELY
CALLING MY NAME WAITING FOR ME.
SO I'M SORRY I'M I'M SORRY NO
YOU ARE BY YEAH. THIS IS MISS
MILLER ARE ONE OF THE PRIME
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT GO AHEAD
MISS MILLER. ONE YOU WILL. HELP
YOU CAN AM I IN YES. WE HEAR THE
PART ABOUT THAT I THOUGHT IT WAS
WITH ME IN UNIFIED ABOUT THAT.
HI WE BIRTH. SECOND DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION APART
THIRTIETH WHICH- CONSISTS OF
ELEVEN COMMERCIAL PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA HERE TODAY. GUITARS
SUPPORT FOR AT THE ELEVEN OH
FOUR. I SENATOR LENA GONZALEZ.
THANK HEALTH REPORTER. FOR
HANDLING 30% OF ALL
CONTAINERISED IMPORTS AND 28% OF
ALL EXPERTS IN THE U. S.
ADDITIONALLY. OVER THREE POINT
ONE MILLION JOBS ARE SUPPORTED
BY TRADE THAT MOVED TO THE
CALIFORNIA PARKS. DESPITE THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF BREAKING
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE AND
ECONOMY THE RECENT SUPPLY CHAIN
PRACTICES SHOWN THAT
CALIFORNIA'S PROTECTOR IS THE
NEED A BETTER PLANNING. AND
COORDINATION ACROSS GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES. IN RESPONSE TO THE
SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS PROVIDED
MINISTRATION RECOGNIZING THE
NEED FOR CENTRALIZED LEADERSHIP
APPOINTED UPPER I'M WAKING ME
ACROSS SECTORS. WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE NATIONAL
SUPPLY CHAIN TO MAKE IT TO
CONGESTION REAL TIME. WITHOUT
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS
APPROACH INVOLVED BENSON KALIFAT
TAKING LEADERSHIP ROLES IN
FACILITATING COORDINATION THERE
IS CURRENTLY NO STATE. CITY
OFFICE. OR POSITION WITH THE
AUTHORITY INCOME HAPPY TO
COORDINATE ACROSS THE ENTIRE
SUPPLY CHAIN SUPPORTING
AGENCIES. CABALLERO ON WITH
OTHER KEY STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
GOODS MOVEMENT SECTOR INCLUDING
GO BAD THINGS HELP THAT. I
PARTICIPATE IN THE CALIFORNIA
SUPPLY CHAIN SIX BACK FROM AT
THE TOP FALL. IN A KEY FINDING
FOR THE BOMBING WHICH INJURED
DROPPED THE COMPLEX CHALLENGES
FACING OUR SUPPLY CHAIN WITH OUR
STATE MUST DEVELOP AND
CENTRALIZED THE OFFICE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IDENTIFYING AND
SETTING CLEAR GOALS. THAT
PROMOTE ECONOMIC COMPETITIVENESS
AT ELEVEN OH FOUR WILL DIRECT
DIRECTLY ADDRESSES%
RECOMMENDATION BY ESTABLISHING
THE UP WITH THE FREE. SERVICE
THE COORDINATING ENTITY THAT
THEIR COMPETITIVENESS AND
SUSTAINABILITY ACROSS EVERY
SECTOR. AS WE LOOK TO THE FUTURE
AND CONTINUE TO WORK ON
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL HELP GET
KIDS MOVING FASTER. WE BELIEVE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND SMARTER
CORONATION WITH AND STATE
LEADERSHIP IS CRITICAL THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
SORRY ABOUT THAT THE HECK UP ON
THE TECH. AS A TECHNOLOGY
APPRECIATE AT. WELL YOU I'M MEHR
MY- DOING ANY. OTHERS IN THE
QUEUE. SUPPORT OF WITNESS. YEAH
RICARDO UP FOR OR OF THE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS RANDOM
WITH THE- RETAILER ASSIST IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
WE HAVE NOT FOR THE SUPPORT
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THEN WE WILL
MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WE DON'T HAVE A PRIMARY
OPPOSITION SO MOVED TO ANY
WITNESSES THAT ARE HERE IN THE%
CHAMBER THAT WOULD LIKE TO
OPPOSE. R. S. B. ELEVEN OH FOUR.
I DON'T SEE ANY THAT WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THOSE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. YOU MIGHT
BE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN OH FOUR
. MADAME MODERATOR THANK YOU CAN
I PUT. IN OPPOSITION OF SB
ELEVEN UP FOR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE
AND THEN CLEAR UP IN OPPOSITION
UP AT THE. ELEVEN OH FOUR. AND
WE HAVE NO OBJECTION IF YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU THEN ALL
OF- OF OUR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WITH WINNERS WITNESSES WILL NOW
MOVE BACK TO THE CHAMBER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SENATOR
GONZALEZ THEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I WOULD JUST SAY I THINK THAT
WITNESSES FOR CALLING IN A
MISTER SCHMELZER FOR RUNNING
OVER HERE TO- TO FIND SUPPORT-
THIS YEAR THE VITAMIN
MINISTRATION ALLOCATED ABOUT
SEVENTEEN BILLION DOLLARS FOR
PORTS- BY CURRENT STANDARDS
WITHOUT HIGH LEVEL COORDINATIO
WE WOULD RECEIVE LESS THAN TWO
BILLION. OVER ELEVEN PORTS IN
CALIFORNIA SO WE NEED TO DO MORE
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IDOL. THANK YOU THEN
CONSULTANTS WHO WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WE DON'T HAVE A
MOTION YET SIR TO HAVE A MOTION
FOR SB ELEVEN OH FOUR SENATOR
DODD. THE ON CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ HI
BATES HI BATES HI ELLEN.
ARCHULETA BAKER. CORTESE CORTESE
II DOLLY. DOT DODD AYE LIMÓN
MCGUIRE REQUIRE HIGH BLOOD THIS
. MEN NEWMAN. RUBIO RUBIO HI
SKINNER WHITE HOUSE SKI. WILK.
THERE'S SIX VOTE SO WE NEED NINE
SO WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL THEN
NOW SENATOR GIRL GONZALEZ WERE
READY FOR YOUR NEXT BILL SB
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE AND YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE BEFORE I
BEGIN I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
THAT WILL REQUIRE THE DMV TO
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
TWENTY TWENTY SIX ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS MEASURE
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT SB
TWELVE THIRTY THREE WHICH
REQUIRES THE DMV TO COORDINATE
WITH RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS TO
DEVELOP OUTREACH STRATEGIES FOR
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
CALIFORNIANS IN CALIFORNIA THERE
ARE AT LEAST TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
LANGUAGES SPOKEN IN 44% OF
RESIDENTS. THAT SPEAK A LANGUAGE
OTHER THAN ENGLISH AT HOME THERE
OVER A HUNDRED LANGUAGES THAT
WHEN CONSIDERED BY COUNTY DO NOT
MEET THE STATE'S 5% THRESHOLD
FOR LANGUAGE SERVICES AT OUR
DMV'S BUT HAVE MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED LANGUAGE SPEAKERS AS A
RESULT DMV SERVICES DO NOT MEET
THE LANGUAGE DIVERSITY NEEDS OF
MANY CALIFORNIANS SB TWELVE
THIRTY THREE WILL ADDRESS THE
SHORTCOMINGS OF ACCESS BY
REQUIRING THE DMV TO WORK WITH
AGAIN STAKEHOLDERS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES TO IDENTIFY THESE
UNDERSERVED GROUPS AND DEVELOP
STRATEGIES AND PROCEDURES AND
HOW TO SERVE THESE POPULATIONS
MORE EFFECTIVELY. ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL CREATES A FORMALIZED
PROTOCOL FOR FACILITATING
OUTREACH EVENTS WITH LOCAL
ENTITIES REPRESENTING THESE VERY
GROUPS TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE TODAY I HAVE A
MESSAGE TO RUN WITH THE MI MIX
DECCA IN THE HANNAH COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING PROJECT THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON SB TWELVE THIRTY THREE THANK
YOU ARE CORRECTING FOR THE
RECORD I SAID SB ELEVEN TWENTY
ONE BUT YOU JUMPED TO. ELEVEN
THIRTY TWELVE THIRTY THREE SO I
APOLOGIZE WITH YOUR PRIMARY
SUPPORT WITNESS FOR A. MISS OF
AN EFFORT TO RUN. THE LIVE HERE
. IN PERSON. YES WELCOME HELLO-
IN THE GALLERY TO RON- GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS VANESSA THAT ON ON THE
POLICY DIRECTOR SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE THIRTY
THREE ON BEHALF OF THE MYSTICAL
IN THE CANNOT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING PROJECT. MICHAEL WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
ONE TO SUPPORT ORGANIZE AND
EMPOWER INDIGENOUS MIGRANTS IN
THE MEXICAN STATE OF OAXACA AND
GUERRERO. INCLUDING MISTAKES
SUPPLE TEXAS AND WOOD APERTURE.
INDIGENOUS MIGRANT POPULATIONS
FACE UNIQUE CHALLENGES INCLUDING
BARRIERS LANGUAGE BARRIERS AS
THEY OFTEN ONLY SPEAK THEIR
NATIVE PRECOLONIAL LANGUAGES.
THEY HAVE DEEP ROOTED CULTURAL
PRACTICES AND BELIEVES. THAT
OFTEN CREATE BARRIERS AND
ISOLATE THEM FROM OTHER MORE
ESTABLISHED LATINO POPULATIONS.
OVER 50% OF FARMWORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE OF INDIGENOUS
MIGRANT THE SENATE. AND MANY
INDIGENOUS FAMILIES EARN MEAGER
WAGES IN CALIFORNIA'S
MULTIBILLION DOLLAR AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY. FURTHERMORE LANGUAGE
BARRIERS PREVENT ACCESS TO
AVAILABLE BASIC HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SUPPORT SERVICES
INCLUDING THE SERVICES THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DMV. GIVEN THE MYRIAD
OF LANGUAGES SPOKEN BY
CALIFORNIANS. THE DMV SERVICES
MUST BE HIGHLY TARGETED AND
FLEXIBLE TO MEET THE LANGUAGE
DIVERSITY NEEDS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS LIKE TWICE DMV
SERVICES WERE ORIGINALLY NOT
DESIGNED FOR CALIFORNIA'S
INDIGENOUS POPULATION MANY
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE MIGRATE FROM
COUNTY TO COUNTY ACROSS THE
STATE FOLLOWING SEASONAL
AGRICULTURAL WORK. T. BE
SERVICES SHOULD BE ADAPTABLE TO
SERVICE THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRANT AND
MIGRANT POPULATION. DUE TO THE
REGIMENTED DAY TO DAY STRUCTURE
. D. B. SERVICES ARE OFTEN
INACCESSIBLE DURING THE TYPICAL
WORK WEEK FOR FARMWORKERS
SATURDAYS ALSO PREVENT
CHALLENGES SINCE AGRICULTURAL
WORK ALSO CONTINUES THROUGH THE
WEEKEND. HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THAT
IN ESTABLISHING S. B. TWELVE
THIRTY THREE THE DEAL BECAUSE
SUPPORT EXPANDING SERVICES TO
OTHER REGIONS OF THE STATE THAT
NEED CULTURAL LINGUISTIC
COMPETENCE SERVICES. SB TWELVE
THIRTY THREE WILL WORK IN
ALIGNMENT WITH KEY STAKEHOLDERS
AND CEO'S WHO KNOW THEIR
CONSTITUENTS FURTHER
STRENGTHENING STRAIGHTENING DMV
COMMUNICATIONS OUTREACH AND
SERVICES TO SHORE ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE GREATER ACCESS
AND EQUITY ON A NUMBER OF DMV
SERVICES INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO RENEWING THEIR
LICENSES PAINS CITATIONS
DOCUMENTING CHANGES OF ADDRESS
AND MORE. REST WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR VOTE ON SB. TWELVE
THIRTY THREE THANK YOU YES YES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- WE
DO NOT HAVE ANOTHER PRIMARY
WITNESS AND SUPPORTS WILL MOVE
TO OTHER WITNESSES WHO ARE HERE
IN THE CHAMBERS WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF S. B.
DENNIS. THIRTEEN TWELVE THIRTY
THREE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
CENTRO CERAM SANTANA
REPRESENTING CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
WE HAVE MORE WITNESSES THAT ARE
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS OR GALLERY
THAT WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THING THEN WE WILL GO TO OF
THOSE WHO IS. WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT VIA TELECONFERENCE THAT
A MODERATOR WERE HUGH UP THOSE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWELVE THIRTY THREE. THANK
YOU YOUR IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
THIRTY THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS THE
ONE AND THEN ZERO FEAR IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE THIRTY
THREE. AND WE HAVE NOT
PORTANTINO AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU ARE HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE A
PRIMARY OPPOSITION SO WE WILL
MOVE TO ANY WITNESSES WHO ARE
HERE IN THE CHAMBER. WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. I DON'T
SEE ANY COMING FORWARD THEN MADE
A MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE WOULD QUEUE
UP ANY OF THOSE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO SB
TWELVE THIRTY THREE. THANK YOU
SB TWELVE THIRTY THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT THE ONE AND THEN ZERO IF
YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWELVE THIRTY THREE. AND WE HAVE
NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU TO ALL OUR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL NOW BRING IT BACK FOR
DISCUSSION TO OUR COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS. CNN.
SENATOR GONZALEZ WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LIKE TO THINK DIRECTOR THAT ON
FOR BEING HERE AND FOR ON THE
WITNESS IN SUPPORT AS WELL- BIG
CHANGES EVEN THOUGH THIS YOU
KNOW IT SEEMS LIKE LOW HANGING
FRUIT THIS IS A HUGE IMPACT FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE UNDERSERVED
AND THAT SPEAK OTHER LANGUAGES
ESPECIALLY THE INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITY IN COMMUNITIES LIKE MY
ON THE CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY WHO
NEED TO SEE REPRESENTATION AT
OUR DMV'S WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIGHT. TO
HAVE A MOTION. MOTION BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE. MISTER CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS A TO PASS AND BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS GONZALEZ I HI SENATE
DEBATES NOT VOTING. ALLEN
ARCHULETA WHICH LETTER I. BAKER
CORTESE. DOLLY DOT DADABHAI
LIMÓN MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO MAN MAN HI
NEWMAN. RUBIO. RUBIO AYE SKINNER
. WHY CASKEY WILK. THAT SIXTY
ONE WILL PUT DOUBLE BILL ON CALL
FOR MEMBERS WHO ARE NOT HERE.
NEXT BILL AND IS THAT GOING TO
BE ELEVEN TWENTY ONE OKAY SB
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE SENATOR
GONZALEZ YOU MAY PROCEED THANK
YOU I KNOW WE'RE ALMOST DONE A
MANAGER SO THANK YOU SO MUCH-
MEMBERS AT CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AS WE KNOW
WHICH INCLUDES ROADS HIGHWAYS
TRANSIT AND BIKE AND PEDESTRIAN
FACILITIES IS SUCH AN ESSENTIAL
PART OF OUR ECONOMIC AND
SOCIETAL INFRASTRUCTURE YET
DESPITE THAT IMPORTANCE WE LACK
A COMPREHENSIVE PICTURE OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING NEEDS FOR
BOTH STATE AND LOCAL FACILITIES
AND HOW THOSE WILL BE MET. SB
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE ADDRESSES THIS
LACK OF INFORMATION BY REQUIRING
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION TO DO THREE THINGS
FIRST AND FOR MOST IMPORTANTLY
THE BILL REQUIRES THE CTT CTC TO
DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE
ASSESSMENT OF HOW MUCH FUNDING
WE WILL NEED TO MAINTAIN AND
CONSTRUCT INFRASTRUCTURE SECOND
THE BILL REQUIRES THE CTC TO
ESTIMATE HOW MUCH FUNDING WE
EXPECT TO HAPPEN FEDERAL STATE
AND LOCAL SOURCES WHAT CAN WE
REALISTICALLY EXPECT THIRD IF
THERE'S A SHORTFALL THE CTC
SHALL RECOMMEND HOW TO ADDRESS
IT. AND IN TURN HELP CANCERS
SUCH A SOME IMPORTANT QUESTIONS
AS WELL DO WE NEED TO PRIORITIZE
OR SPEND LESS ARE THERE
EFFICIENCIES WE CAN DEPLOY SO
THAT WE CAN DO MORE WITH
EXISTING RESOURCES OR DO WE NEED
MORE RESOURCES OVERALL WITH THIS
INFORMATION POLICYMAKERS LIKE
OURSELVES STAKEHOLDERS AND
ADVOCATES CAN DO A BETTER JOB OF
PLANNING FOR FUTURE TO CREATE
THE TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM THAT
MEETS OUR NEEDS AND OUR
RESOURCES TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE TODAY I HAVE
MARC WATTS WITH TRANSPORTATION.
CALIFORNIA WHO SHOULD BE HERE IN
THE GALLERY. AND THERE ARE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES I BELIEVE BOTH
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS- MISTER
WALKS. AND CHRIS LEAK CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BURST
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES HERE THIS MORNING IN
SUPPORT I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
GOALS OF THIS BILL WE THINK THIS
IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
EXERCISE FOR THE STATE TO DO.
IT'S SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN DOING
EVERY TWO YEARS AT THE CITY
COUNTY AND REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION LEVEL LOOKING AT
THE LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS
NEEDS ASSESSMENT ACROSS THE
STATE. AND WE THINK NEEDS
ASSESSMENTS IN GENERAL ARE A
GREAT WAY TO HELP DEFINE GOALS
REALLY PUT A FIRM NUMBER AROUND
WHAT THINGS COST BUT ALSO TO
HELP ILLUSTRATE THE TRADEOFFS
THAT WE FACE SO FOR INSTANCE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT TRADE OFF BETWEEN
MAINTAINING OUR EXISTING SYSTEM.
AND MEETING THE CHALLENGES OF
TRANSFORMING IT TO BETTER MEET
TODAY'S TRANSPORTATION GOAL SO
WHAT IS THE SCOPE OF THE PROJECT
HOW DO WE PROVIDE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION SAFE ACCESS FOR
BICYCLISTS AND PEDESTRIANS AND
BALANCE THAT WITH THE NEEDS FOR
SYSTEM PRESERVATION. AND WE ALSO
THINK THAT SIMPLY BY MEASURING
IN ASKING THESE QUESTIONS WE CAN
HELP DRIVE POLICY CHANGES JUST A
FEW EXAMPLES OF OUR MOST RECENT
LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS NEEDS
ASSESSMENT. 88% OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE NOW USING A
PAVEMENT MANAGEMENT SYSTEM TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE REALLY
EFFICIENTLY APPLYING THEIR
MAINTENANCE TECHNIQUES THAT'S
REPRESENTING OVER 98% OF THE
LOCAL LANE MILES WE SEEM HUGE
GROWTH IN THE NUMBER OF
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE DOING
COMPREHENSIVE COMPLETE STREETS
POLICIES. TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
EIGHT IN OUR TWENTY TWENTY
SURVEY WHICH IS THREE TIMES AS
MANY AS WE'RE DOING THAT WE
STARTED DOING THE SURVEY SURVEY
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT. AND
FINALLY AGAIN IN OUR TWENTY
TWENTY SURVEY WE SAW THAT 76% OF
LOCAL AGENCIES ARE STARTING TO
USE SUSTAINABLE PAVING PRACTICES
LIKE RECYCLING AND THINGS OF
THAT NATURE AND SO INSTANCE JUST
SAID OF JUST MEASURING KIND OF
THE CONDITIONS IN THE FUNDING
NEEDS. IT REALLY FOCUSES
ATTENTION ON TRADE OFFS ON
POLICY IMPROVEMENTS AND OTHER
CREATIVE APPROACHES THAT WE KNOW
WE NEED TO TAKE TO REALLY
ADEQUATELY MAINTAIN OUR SYSTEM
AND IMPROVE IT FOR TODAY'S
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS AND WE
THINK THIS BILL IS A GREAT STEP.
TO GET THE STATE MOVING IN THAT
DIRECTION IN A COMPREHENSIVE WAY
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE SUPPORT
. THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
LEAVE FOR YOUR TESTIMONY US MR
WATER FLOODS HERE OR PERHAPS ON
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE THAT A
MODERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES AND SEE IF OUR PRIMARY
WITNESS MISTER WHAT MIGHT BE OR
WANTING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE. WHAT IF YOU
AREN'T YOU MAY PRESS STAR ZERO.
THE. I DO NOT SEE HIM ON. IT
WILL MOVE ONE MOMENT PLEASE YEP
I FOUND THEM ONE MOMENT PLEASE
OKAY. MISTER WHAT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN.
I'M. YEP MISTER WHAT'S YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FIRST OF ALL TO
THE OPPORTUNITY HERE TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I APOLOGIZE IF
JACKLEY. BAIT MAKING AN ERROR
BEING AT THE WRONG PLACE AT THE
WRONG TIME HOWEVER. I AM MARC
WATTS AND RIVETING
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS THE- WHICH IS A SUPPORTER. OF
THIS MEASURE WE ARE THE INDUSTRY
AND HAVE THE MEN AND WOMEN IN
THE BILL ARE TRANSPORTATION
MOBILITY SYSTEMS. SUPPORT THE
MEASURE AND WOULD NOTE THAT
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA WAS
THE SPONSOR OF SENATOR BURDENS
SENATE RESOLUTION EIGHT OF
NINETEEN NINE NINE THAT IS NOTED
IN THE ANALYSIS. WE THIS BILL
WILL FACILITATE A CARPENTER
GOING. OF THE STATE OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. AND WE
THINK THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT AT
THIS POINT IN TIME IT'S CLIMATE
CHALLENGES CONTINUE. AND
RESILIENCY NEEDS ARE INCREASING
AND MOBILITY SYSTEMS ARE
BEGINNING OKAY. AND AS OUR
OVERALL BAKER THEMAJORS. THIS
BILL WILL GIVE US A CRITICAL
UNDERSTANDING- TO MEET OUR
STATE'S FUTURE NEEDS. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
AND WE ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER
WATSON WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ANY
WITNESSES WHO ARE HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. I DO NOT SEE
ANY THEN WILL NOW MOVE INTO THE
WITNESSES WAITED WAITING TO
TESTIFY. VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE AND THESE WOULD BE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SO IF YOU
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY META
MODERATOR IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU IF
YOU'RE PART OF SB A LEVIN TWENTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO CURRENT COURT AS HE ALLOWED
TWENTY ONE. AND WE WILL GO TO
BRIAN A FORTY THREE YEAR
LIGHTNESS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE GENTLEMAN THING ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN COUNCIL OF
ENGINEERING COMPANIES CALIFORNIA
AND SPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL GO TO LIGHTEN UP
FORTY FIVE YEAR LIFE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES MY
NAME'S UNION ON BEHALF OF.
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON AMERICAN
ISLAMIC RELATIONS NINETY FOUR SB
ONE SIX ONE. FIVE THREE YEARS
ALONE OVER TWO HUNDRED FEET
CRIME. INCIDENTS HAVE BEEN
REPORTED. VERY FROM BILL NOW.
I'M SORRY PART AT E. ELEVEN
TWENTY ONE. THEN WE HAVE ANOTHER
NOT FOR THEIR SUPPORT IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU THEN WE
DON'T WE DON'T HAVE ANY PRIMARY
OPPOSITION TO A MOVE TO ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WHO ARE
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS. ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. I DO NOT SEE ANY. IN
MOVE INTO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION VIA
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR IF YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR THE
HOUSE FOR OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
THANK YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION I
HAVE AS AND B. ELEVEN TWENTY ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN ONE AND THEN ZERO IN
OPPOSITION OF THE ALADDIN.
TWENTY ONE. AND WE HAD NO
OPPOSITION QUEUE AT THE SITE.
WELL THANK YOU TO ALL THOSE WHO
SPOKE IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
TWENTY ONE WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE MEMBERS
OF A ANY DISCUSSION CONCERNS
COMMENTS. THEN SENATOR GONZALEZ
I DON'T SEE ANY COUNT UP SO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON SB. ELEVEN TWENTY ONE.
FROM SENATOR MAN. MOVES MAMMUT
THEM CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS GONZALEZ
I DOLLARS AYE BATES. ALLEN
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA BAKER.
CORTESE DOLLY. DOT DODD AYE
BATES AYE BATES AYE. LIMON
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN MAN I
NEWMAN. RUBIO RUBIO HI SKINNER.
BY CASKEY WILK. HE. WE HAVE SIX
VOTES IN FAVOR AND WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN- WILL MOVE TO B.
TWELVE FIFTY ONE I BELIEVE
SENATOR GONZALEZ YES. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- I WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT SB TWELVE FIFTY ONE
WHICH WILL CREATE A ZERO
EMISSION EQUITY AB ADVOCATE IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE YOUR
MISSION VEHICLES INCLUDING
PASSENGER VEHICLES BUSES AND
TRUCKS ARE ESSENTIAL TO REDUCE
OUR STATE'S GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND AIR POLLUTION THAT
HARMS SO MANY CALIFORNIANS
HOWEVER ACCESS TO THAT ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. IS CURRENTLY
NOT EQUITABLE IN CALIFORNIA
WHITE HIGHER INCOME HOPE
HOUSEHOLDS ARE FAR MORE LIKELY
TO OWN ZEVON'S THEN LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS OF COLOR IRONICALLY
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE IN
EMISSIONS BURDEN COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE THE MOST NEED FOR M.
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES SB TWELVE
FIFTY ONE WILL TACKLE THE ISSUE
BY CREATING A ZERO EMISSION
EQUITY ADVOCATE. THAT WILL SERVE
AS A CENTRALIZED ENTITY TO PUT
EQUITY FRONT AND CENTER IN THE
STATE'S ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
DEPLOYMENT PLAN AND ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITIES WHO NEED IT THE MOST
HAVE ACCESS RESERVE EQUITY
ADVOCATE WILL ALSO PROVIDE A
CENTRALIZED LOCATION AT THE
STATE FOR COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
AND MORE WORK TO ALIGN. EQUITY
DEFINITIONS GOALS AND
INVESTMENTS ACROSS STATE
AGENCIES TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL TODAY HAVE MICHELLE
CAN MEN FROM THE SENIOR DIRECTOR
OF THE LOS ANGELES CLEANTECH
INCUBATOR AND VANESSA MARLON THE
WESTERN STATES PROGRAM MANAGER
FOR EVEY HYBRID LAW THINKING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON SB TWELVE FIFTY ONE. THANK
YOU LET'S GO OUR PRIME PRIME
WITNESSES WHO ARE WHO ARE ON THE
PHONE AND WILL BEGIN WITH ON
THIS VANESSA MARLIN. THAT
CORRECT. YES THAT IS CORRECT
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK. YEAH WONDERFUL YOU
SOMETHING THAT THE MORE LINE I'M
THE WESTERN STATE PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR EATING A ARE AND ET
HARPER TO OUR OUR NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS ARE COMMITTED TO
ENDING RACIAL DISPARITIES AFFECT
THE CLEAN ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
GREEN JOB CREATION I WANT TO
THINK SENATORS INVOLUNTARY
LEADERSHIP AND PARTNERSHIP
WORKING WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ADVOCATE TO DEVELOP SB
TWELVE FIFTY ONE I'M HERE TODAY
TO- YOU TO SUPPORT SB TWELVE
FIFTY ONE WHICH WILL CREATE A
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE OR THAT
ACTUALLY ADVOCATE WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. A CALIFORNIA
MOVES TOWARD IS ENVISIONED THAT
GOLD WHEN YOU DOUBLE THE STATE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ENSURING WE ARE
ALSO ADVANCING I BELIEVE I
POLICIES CALIFORNIA IS THE WORLD
LEADER IN THE THAT MARKET
HOWEVER ON THE SENATE MENTION
LAW INCOME HOUSEHOLD AND HELP
WITH THE COLOR ARE FAR LESS
LIKELY TO OWN NINE IN WHITE
HIGHER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS PART OF
MY CURRENT ROLE I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
THAT COULD DIRECTLY THROUGH THE
BAY AREA CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
PROGRAM WHICH IS A FIRST COME
FIRST SERVE PROGRAMS AND CAN
LEAD TO AN ACTUAL DISTRIBUTION
OF IN. I UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO
HAVE AN EQUITY TO ENSURE OUR
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION ITS
EQUITABLE AND LEAD TO LONG TERM
ACCESS FOR COMMUNITIES THAT CAN
BENEFIT THE. MOST
ELECTRIFICATION. I TWELVE FIFTY.
HUNDRED FOR CURRENT EQUITY OF
THE- BY CREATING THE OFFICE OF
THE DAY EQUITY. IF HELP PROVIDE
AND JUSTICE AB WITH SINGLE AND-
TO HOLD ACCOUNTABLE FOR AND SHE
AND JUST IT'S- AND TRANSIT. MAKE
IT MORE AND EFFECTIVE FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVOCATE
IN TRACKING INFLUENCE THAN
TWENTY AGENCIES THAT POLICIES
MATTER AND PROVIDING INDEPENDENT
VOICE TO EVALUATE CALIFORNIA'S
PROGRESS TOWARD EQUITABLY
ACHIEVING THE STATE EXAMPLES.
ANY ACTION AT THE TWELVE THIRTY
ONE ONE SURE THAT THE STATE IS
MOVING TOWARDS EFFECTIVE
COMMUNITY CENTER THAT ACTUALLY
GOLD IN THE MOST EFFICIENT AND
TRANSPARENT MANNER POSSIBLE. I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
AND WELCOME MY PARTNER MICHELLE
FROM LACI TO ADDITIONALLY
PROVIDING TESTIMONY. ON SB
TWELVE FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU MISS
MORE AND WE WILL GO TO ARMS CAN
ARE WHO IS TO TEST IN SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MICHELLE COMMITTEE WITH THE LOS
ANGELES CLEANTECH INCUBATOR OR
LEAFY. THANK YOU SENATOR
GONZALEZ FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
FOR WORKING HAND IN HAND WITH
THE C. AND OUR ALLIES IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE SECTOR
WE'RE TRULY DEVELOPED SB TWELVE
FIFTY ONE. I CALIFORNIA TO
ACHIEVE OUR CRITIC IMPORTANT
GOALS TO TRANSITION CAR TRUCKS
AND BUSES ZERO EMISSION. AT THE
STATE INVESTING TO GET FUNDING
TO SUPPORT THE TRANSITION. THE
PROPOSAL THAT WE SENT IN EQUITY
AGENDA FOR THE DEPLOYMENT OF
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE. THE
SUPPORTING INFRASTRUCTURE. IN
RELATED WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
THAT'S THE IDEA BEHIND SB TWELVE
FIFTY ONE. THE OFFICE OF THOSE
AS EQUITY ADVOCATE WOULD
FACILITATE CONNECTIONS BETWEEN
COMMUNITY GROUPS AND AGENCIES
REGARDING EXACTLY. WHAT A LINE
EQUITY DEFINITIONS PLANNING AND
- ACROSS AGENCIES AND PROGRAMS.
AND EVALUATE STATE PROGRAMS AND
FUNDING FOR EQUITABLE THAT
DEPLOYMENT PROVIDING REGULAR
DATA AND REPORTS ON HOW WELL THE
CITY IS. AN EYE WHAT ABOUT THAT
THE. NO TODAY WE MULTIPLE PROBE
THAT WORKING FUND ON THE FIRST
COME FIRST SERVE BASIS. IN SOME
CASES THE FOR ARE SO THE
SUBSCRIBER WITHIN SECONDS. AND
ONE THING AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REFINE THE PROGRAM TO ENSURE
CREATING IMPACT FOR HIGHLY
POLLUTED COMMUNITIES. AND THI
IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF THE TYPE
OF RECOMMENDATION THAT COULD BE
MADE BY THE THOUGHT THAT WOULD
BE ACTED. TO ENSURE THAT THE
INVESTMENTS WE'RE MAKING AT THE
STATE ARE SPENDING WAYS THAT ARE
ACTIVE AND EFFICIENT IN
ADVANCING OUR COMMITMENT TO AN
EQUITABLE THAT TRANSITION. THIS
IS A CONCEPT THAT FROM NEXT.
WITH ALLIES IN THE ENVIRONMENT
JUSTICE FACE. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY I FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS CAN
AND WILL NOW HERE FROM OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YOU MIGHT
BE HERE IN THE CHAMBERS OR ANY-
WITNESSES HERE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. YOU DON'T SEE
ANY THEN LET US MOVE TO THE A
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS ARE WAITING
TO SUPPORT. OUR SB TWELVE FIFTY
ONE ON THE TELECONFERENCE LINE
SO MODERATOR WILL YOU PLEASE Q.
THOSE UP. THANK YOU. FOR W. F.
B. TWELVE FIFTY ONE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO YOU
AREN'T SUPPORT AT B. WELL FIFTY
ONE. ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GET
RESERVE MY NUMBER. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE AT SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MANJERI
MEMBERS SYLVIA PHILLIES SHOP ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR TO LINE
TWENTY SEVEN YEAR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING MAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ANDREA OUT WITH THE K. MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES. AND WE SUPPORT SB
TWELVE THIRTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO LINE
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
WITH GO AHEAD. THE MORNING AND
MEDICAL ON WITH TRIPLE A AND-
THANK YOU AND ONE MOMENT WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE IN THE QUEUE. WE
WILL GO TO LINE SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING WHAT DO YOU DO
THINGS WITH THE CLIMATE CENTER
IN SUPPORT- SB TWELVE- FIFTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
THEN WE WILL MOVE TO THE
OPPOSITION AND LOOK TO SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY UP HERE IN THE
CHURCH- GALLERY FOR THE CHAMBERS
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
. TWO U. S. B. TWELVE FIFTY ONE.
SEEING NONE THERE NOW WE WILL GO
TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINES AND
OPEN THOSE FOR ANYONE WHO'S
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO S. B. R. TWELVE FIFTY ONE. AT
A MODERATE GIVEN UP IF. IN
OPPOSITION OF AT BE A FIFTY ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
. AGAIN THAT ONE AND THEN FEEL
FREE IN OPPOSITION- UP AT B.
TWELVE FIFTY ONE. AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION TO QUEUE AT THIS TIME
. THEN IT WE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE AND ASK IF
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS- HI. TWELVE FIFTY ONE.
AND ARCHULETA YES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I'D LIKE TO
COMPLIMENT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LONG BEACH IS A GREAT BILL I'D
LIKE TO BE A CO AUTHOR IF I MAY
AND ALSO IF WE CAN ENSURE. FUEL
CELL HYDROGEN. INTO IT AS IT
MOVES ALONG I WOULD APPRECIATE
IT. AND THANK YOU MANAGER THANK
YOU. THEN SENATOR GONZALEZ YOU
MAY CLOSE. I'M SORRY SENATOR MAN
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS FOR THIS BILL- AND- I GUESS
MY ONLY QUESTION OR MAYBE IT'S
MORE OF A- MY ONLY CONCERN IS I
YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S ONE THING
TO HAVE A VOICE AND A VOICE IS
POWERFUL AS WE KNOW HAVING A
SEAT AT THE TABLE IS IMPORTANT-
BUT I'D ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONSIDER. WHETHER IN THIS
LEGISLATION OR PERHAPS GOING
FORWARD IN FOLLOWING UP AS WE
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE ROLE OF
THIS ADVOCATE- WHETHER WE CAN
PROVIDE THEM WITH SOME ACTUAL
POWER TO ENFORCE TO IMPLEMENT-
SO THAT IT'S NOT JUST A MATTER
OF A VOICE THAT MAY OR MAY NOT
BE HEARD SO I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO AND- IT
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO KEEP
THINKING FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YEAH YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS BY MY COLLEAGUES
ABSOLUTELY WILL WILL LOOK AT ALL
FACTORS YOU KNOW JUST. THE
IMAGES FOR THIS BILL WAS. OR SO
MANY AGENCIES DEALING WITH YOUR
MISSION CARS ETCC SCENE YOU NAME
IT. THIS IS TO CONSOLIDATE THEM
WITH THE WITH OF COURSE EQUITY
FIRST- AND LOWERING EMISSIONS-
IN ANY- OPPORTUNITY POSSIBLE AND
I WANT TO THANK MISS MARLIN AND
MIST CAN THEN. OFFER THEIR
SUPPORT AS WELL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE. SB
TWELVE FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU FOR
MOTION. SENATOR DODD MOVED- S.
B. FOUR FIFTY ONE- CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS AND SALAS HI BATES NO
BATES NOAH ALLEN. ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA I BECKER CORTESE DOLLY
. DALY NO DOT DONNA HI RAMON
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MELINDA'S NOW
MAN MEN I NEWMAN. RUBIO SKINNER
CASKEY WILK. OF THAT FORTY THREE
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR APPS
MEMBERS AND I WILL TURN THE
GAVEL BACK OVER TO SENATOR
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
JOB WELL DONE MADAM VICE CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY NOW WE
WILL- PROCEED WITH OUR NEXT
BILL. WHICH WILL BE BY SENATOR
MAN- SB ELEVEN SIXTY ONE YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU SENATOR MAN
THANK YOU CHAIR GONZALEZ I'M
SORRY.
THANK YOU DEAR GONZALEZ THANK
YOU TO YOUR STAFF HAVE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH US ON THIS
BILL. I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB
ELEVEN SIXTY ONE WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE THE TEN LARGEST PUBLIC
TRANSIT OPERATORS CALIFORNIA. TO
CONDUCT RESEARCH ON HARASSMENT
EXPERIENCED BY WRITERS AND USE
THAT DATA TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT POLICIES TO PRIORITIZE
RATE RIDER SAFETY COMFORT AND
DIGNITY. UNFORTUNATELY TOO MANY
OF US ARE FAMILIAR WITH SAFETY
CHALLENGES WHEN USING PUBLIC
TRANSIT. MANY OF US HAVE HAD TO
OR NO ONE ELSE SOMEONE ELSE
WHO'S HAD TO CHANGE A TRANSIT
ROUTE TO AVOID HARASSMENT. THE
DATA SHOWS THAT HARASSMENT ON
PUBLIC TRANSIT UNFORTUNATELY
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS WOMEN.
LGBTQ PUS RIDERS MINORITIES AND
OTHER VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
ACCORDING TO TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN STATEWIDE STUDY BY THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO
CENTER ON GENDER EQUITY AND
HEALTH. 77% OF WOMEN HAD
EXPERIENCED SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN
A PUBLIC SPACE INCLUDING 29% IN
MASS TRANSIT. THIS IS EVEN MORE
COMMON WITH WOMEN HO IDENTIFY.
AS LESBIAN OR BISEXUAL. AND AS
WE SEEM THE CALL NINETY PENDING
. HARASSMENT AGAINST A AMERICANS
IN HIS ISLANDERS ON A SHARP
INCREASE. SINCE MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY THE STOP ÁP I HATE
COALITION HAS RECEIVED OVER TEN
THOUSAND REPORTS OF HATE
INCIDENTS AGAINST ASIAN
AMERICANS AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
FROM ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AND
ALMOST 50% OF THOSE INCIDENTS
TOOK PLACE AT PUBLIC VENUES
INCLUDING STREETS IN PARKS AND
ON TRANSIT. IN ADDITION API'S
BLACK WOMEN LATINO WOMEN WOMEN
OF COLOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THE L. G. B. Q. AND
T. G. I. COMMUNITIES IN YOUNG
AND ELDERLY ALSO EXPERIENCE.
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARES OF
STREET HARASSMENT ON TRANSIT.
THIS IS A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
AND ONE WE HAVE TO ADDRESS NOW
AND SB ELEVEN SIXTY ONE WOULD
TAKE A SIGNIFICANT STEP TOWARD
STOPPING THAT CYCLE HARASSMENT.
BY AGAIN REQUIRING THE STATE'S
TEN LARGEST TRANSIT OPERATORS TO
COLLECT RIDERSHIP DATA AND TO
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT POLICIES
TO SUPPORT SAFE TRANSIT
EXPERIENCES. WITH ME HERE TO
TESTIFY IN PERSON I HAVE SENT
THE CHECK FROM STOP ÁP I HATE.
AND ON THE PHONE I HAVE ALEX
AMADEO ON BEHALF OF ELEMENTARY.
THANK YOU SENATOR MEN- WE'LL
START WITH MISS INDIA CHOI-
FROM. A STOP AP I HATE WELCOME
MYSTERY. GOOD MY NAME IS CYNTHIA
CHE AND I'M THE CO EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. ONE OF THE
CO FOUNDERS OF STOPPING I HATE
THE COALITION TO ADDRESS RACISM
AGAINST API'S NATIONWIDE. I AM
PLEASED TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB ELEVEN SIXTY ONE A BILL TO
INCREASE RIDER SAFETY ON PUBLIC
TRANSIT WHERE TO OFTEN
HARASSMENT OCCURS. WE ARE PROUD
TO JOIN WITH L. A. METRO AS A
SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND APPLAUD
SENATOR MAN FOR HIS LEADERSHIP.
SINCE THE START OF KOBE NINETEEN
ENDEMIC STUCK BAKER I HATE HAS
RECEIVED NEARLY ELEVEN THOUSAND
REPORTS OF HATE INCIDENTS FROM
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. MORE THAN
FOUR THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED PORTS
IN CALIFORNIA ALONE. A MAJORITY
OF THESE INCIDENTS WERE REPORTED
BY API WOMEN AND THE VAST
MAJORITY WERE HONDA THAT IS NOT
A CRIME SUCH AS BARBARA SMITH.
ABOUT THE SINCE OCCURRED IN
PUBLIC SPACES SUCH AS SIDEWALKS
PARKS AND TRANSIT. WE KNOW THAT
HARASSMENT ON TRANSIT DOES NOT
ONLY IMPACT API'S IT ALSO
AFFECTS BLACK AND LATINO WOMEN
AND GIRLS AS WELL AS THE L.
COMMUNITY. TO GIVE YOU I. OF
WHAT EIGHT SEVEN X. ON. ACROSS
STATE HERE ARE SOME OF THE
STORIES OF- IN THEIR OWN WORDS
AND I APOLOGIZE THERE ARE.
CHILDREN OF FROZEN- I AM VERY
SELF CONSCIOUS AS A MOTHER-
POLITIES- SO ONE EXAMPLE IS THE
DUDE WAS HARASSING ME AT THE
KALMAR STATION AND CALLED ME
AGING BAGGAGE ASIAN CORONA AND
GO OUT ON THE SAME TRAIN BUT
WASN'T SATISFIED AND CALM.
FOLLOWED ME CARD A CARD SO I GOT
OFF AND HOPPED ON ANOTHER TRAIN
FOR MY SAFETY AND OTHERS ANOTHER
RECORDED I WAS WAITING FOR A BUS
AT NIGHT AFTER CONCERT AT
HOLLYWOOD BOWL A MAN NEAR THE
STOPS ARE REPEATEDLY SCREAMING
TOKYO AND CLICK WHO NEED SHE
WHILE. AT ME I TRIED TO MOVE
AWAY FROM THE MAN TO MAKE SURE
MY BACK WAS AGAINST THE WALL THE
WAY FOR THE BUS WAS TWENTY TO
THIRTY MINUTES SO I USED TO RIDE
CHER AT TO GET HOME. THESE
EXPERIENCES ARE FAR TOO COMMON
SO WE HAD. NINETY US FOR YOUR
FIVE. ON S. B. ELEVEN SIX ONE
WHICH TO MAKE TRANSIT SAFER FOR
EVERYONE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS J. NEXT WE HAVE OUR LEAD
WITNESS IN SUPPORT- MISTER
MICHAEL TURNER FROM LA METRO WHO
IS ON THE COASTLINE. PART I'M
SORRY WE HAVE ANOTHER A LEADING
WITNESS IN SUPPORT ON THE CO
HOST MIND SO WILL ENSURE THAT-
MODERATOR IF YOU HAVE THE
ADDITIONAL LEAD WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. OF A. ELEVEN SIXTY ONE.
AND HOW DO I LIVE UP IN BECAUSE
- GOOD MORNING OUT OF THE DAY-
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS OFFICER ON
BEHALF OF DELHI METRO THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE FOR
THE HEARING I THANK YOU TO
SENATOR MAN PROCTOR. SB SIXTY.
ELEMENTARY PROUD TO BE A CALL
SPONSOR OF THE BILL ALONG WITH
THIS A- HE CALLED. VETERANS LAW
LEAD THE WAY IN A THIS CONCERNS
OF POP. WHO RELY ON OR TRY.
DAILY LIFE. THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT EVERYONE. THREE THREE AND
FEEL FREE OF. BY OTHER ARE
SYSTEM. METRICS TAKING THE LEAD
THE DRESSING THE ISSUE BY FOR
PUTTING IN. FOR WOMEN AND
GOVERNING COUNCIL. AND BY
DEVELOPING THE CON.
TRANSPORTATION REPORT. HOW DO.
THE REPORT FOCUSES ON VERY
CONCERN THAT NGUYEN IN PART.
FACE WRITING ARTISTS. BUT THESE
CONCERNS ARE UNITS. ACROSS
DIFFERENT. AND OUR SUPPLY.
MEASURE IMPLEMENTING THE REST.
REPORT TO CONTINUE THE WORK OF
THE- HOW. WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
WILL CREATE A MODEL FOR HOW
TRANS AGENCY COMMITTEE THE NEED
OF VULNERABLE POP. AND I FEEL
SIXTY ONE CREATE THE FRAME BY
WHICH THAT CAN. THE BILL PART
TRANSIT AGENCIES SURVEYED
WRITERS HARAPPAN THEY'VE MADE.
AND THE AGENCY TO PUT MY IN
PLACE TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. WE
THAT THE FRAMERS OF NOT ONLY
APPROPRIATE CREEK A MODEL FOR
HOW TRANSIT AGENCIES CAN DRESS
GROWING. OF HARASSMENT AGAINST
VOTER POPULATIONS IN OUR SOCIETY
THANK YOUNG RESPECTFULLY AFTER
I'VE OF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT CONCLUDES OUR LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN SIXTY ONE SO WE'LL TAKE
IT TO. THE GALA AND HE WITNESSED
. IN OF S. B. ELEVEN SIXTY ONE.
PART OF THE SIXTY ONE THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING ANYWAY ON BEHALF
OF CHINESE FOR AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION IN SUPPORT OF SB. ELEVEN
SIXTY ONE. GOOD MORNING VANESSA
SAID ON IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
SYSTEM SIXTY ONE. GREAT TO HAVE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
C. NINE SO MODERATOR WILL TAKE
IT BACK TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE FOR ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF L. S. ELEVEN SIXTY
ONE. THANK YOU. PART OF SB
ELEVEN SIXTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS
ONE AND THEN THE APPEARANCE
PARKED UP AT THE ALLOTMENTS ONE.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD- GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALCHEMY GRAHAM
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION. OF THE APPLICATION
WHICH REPRESENTS THE TEN TRANSIT
AGENCIES IMPACTED BY THE BILL
ACTUALLY CURRENTLY HAS NO
POSITION ON SB ELEVEN SIXTY ONE.
BUT WITH THAT BEING SAID WE
WANTED TO APPEAR BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TO NOTE THAT WE WORKED
CLOSELY AND PRODUCTIVELY WITH
THE AUTHOR IN ON SEARCH INCREASE
YOU TO REVIEW THE BILL AT THE
STATE. SEVENTH THANK WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR HAS
ATTRACTED MANY OF THE ISSUES WE
PRIVATE THE BILL AS INITIALLY
INTRODUCED AND WE ARE COMMITTED
TO. CONTINUING TO WORK WITHOUT
FUNDS ARE AT THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD TO ADDRESS AND YOUR
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE IN SUPPORT. OF SB ELEVEN
SIXTY ONE. EIGHT YOU. WITHOUT
TELLING SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN WE'VE GOT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MY WE SHOULD SAY OF THEM
FROM SOUTH ASIAN- IN ORDER. THAT
SERVE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE IN TELEVISION. AND I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B.
ELEVEN SIXTY ONE I AND I THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. IN THE BOTTOM LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS WILL BE MY DOCTOR
DIRECTOR LINES WORLD IN THE FAR
REGIONAL ONLINE THIRTY WORKING.
I'M CALLING TO EXPRESS MY VERY
FOR SUPPORT FOR A B. BOB SIXTY
ONE THE BILL ABOUT WILL SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IS HER. THAT IMPACT
HOLDEN CHEN THEIR EXPENSE IF YOU
. BUILT ACCORDING WE'VE BEEN
ABLE WORK HERE LOS WITH ART
THANK YOU MA'AM WE'RE JUST NAY
AN ORGAN- IN SOME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WERE GOING TO TURN
THAT SIDE OF FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. A GOOD MORNING NAME IS AN
EVEN MORE ON BEHALF OF THESE
HIGH COMMUNITY DOES SYNDROME LAS
AND- ARE WE SAYING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ABOUT THE
LINE FOR FOUR YOU ALAINA OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS BERNICE THE FATHER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING. THE BIG
ISLAND AMERICANS. GOOD FOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BOTH SO I'M FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JEANNIE IN
THE PARKING ARE RECORDED EITHER
ON BEHALF OF CARE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL CAN. OR SB ONE. IN YOU
IMPORTANT AT THIS THANK YOU VERY
SO WE'VE CONCLUDED SUPPORT SO
WE'LL MOVE ON TO- ANY LEAD
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NONE SO IS
THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO S.
ELEVEN SIXTY ONE IN THE GALLERY
. WE SEE NONE A MODERATE WILL
TAKE IT BACK TO YOU ANY
WITNESSES IN THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE IN OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN
SIXTY ONE PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
IN OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN SIXTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR ANY OPPOSITION S. B.
SIXTY ONE. AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION TO KEEP AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU WE'VE CONCLUDED
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION SO WE'LL
TAKE THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
MEMBERS. MANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SENATOR ARCHERS OF
THANK YOU MANAGER I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR GREAT BILL- MY
DISTRICT. WITH THE
TRANSPORTATION WE HAVE NUMBER OF
UNDERSERVED THAT WE HAVE THE API
THAT WE HAVE- I'D BE HONORED TO
BE A CO AUTHOR AND- I'D LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL IT'S BROUGH TIME.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO ARCHER.
RESHAPE THAT AND- I DON'T SEE
ANY MAKES UP I WILL SAY SENATOR
THINK YOU MUCH FOR BRING THIS
PHONE I KNOW. I. T. WORKED WITH
YOUR TEAM- TWO INCH THAT WE GOT
THAT THE LANGUAGE RIGHT BUT- LET
ME. STOP THERE GOOD AS THE VICE
. SENATOR BATES. I DIDN'T GET MY
HAVE MY AM MIKE UP QUICKLY. I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL. TODAY
BUT I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE COSTS THAT MIGHT GO TO OUR
TRANSFERRED. AGENCY SO. FORWARD
ASANA. I'VE YOU. CALL ON THAT.
AND NOT INSURE. ALL THAT TO DO
SOME. THAT IS GOING. BE A
AFFORDABLE AND NOT. FROM WAYS
I'M COMES. ABOUT THE- BY. THAT
ARE LOCAL AGENCIES SO JUST STOP
. PEHLU BIT. ABOUT IF YOU WILL.
THEN- I MISS. TODAY I THINK IT'S
AN OLD. CAR THANK YOU. AND IF I
COULD READ. I THE- QUESTION
CENTER- OR THE- CONCERN. AND
WHEN I. AND I SHOULD. THAT WE
ARE ASKING FOR. BUDGET AT. TO
COVER THE- OF SO. WITH THIS IS
THAT IS. A TOP. FOR THIS. EIGHT
HEY- ORGANIZATION. AND OF OTHER
API GROUPS. THEY'VE IS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I CENTER MEN WANT
THANK YOU FOR THIS FOR THIS AND
WORK ON A YOU WORK WITH THEM
ANYWAY HERE TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN
AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR OF MANY- P.
ORGANIZED AND MEMBERS AND
MICHAEL- WHO WITH- ASKING FOR
SOMETHING LIKE THIS A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT REALLY- HONORS
AND THEM BUT ALSO LOOKS AT TO
ENSURE THAT WERE STOPPING THIS
TYPE OF HATE AT OUR TRANSIT
SYSTEM SO WITH THAT- WE'VE
ENTERTAINED A MOTION BY SENATOR
ARE. MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL UP MY
APOLOGIES WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE- I JUST WANNA SAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU HAVE A
GREAT MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT
NOW I MAKE A CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DUE. AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY.
CERAGON HI GONZALEZ I BATES.
BATES I ALLEN. ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA. BAKER CORTESE. DOLLY
DOLLY I DOT DONNA LIMO. MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ. MIN HI BEEN I NEWMAN
NEWMAN AYE RUBIO RUBIO HI
SKINNER MY CASKET WHY CASKEY I
WILL. OKAY NINE VOTES IT SEEMS
TO BE OUT BUT WILL LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL FOR ADDITIONAL
ACOSTA MEMBERS THINK IT
MANAGEMENT. GREAT SO THAT CAN
CAUSE OUR- AGENDA AT THIS POINT
THE LOCAL AND LIVE SOME CALLS ON
THE BILLS AND I BELIEVE WE'LL
HAVE TO WAIT FOR OTHER MEMBERS
AS WELL TO COME BACK. WHEN I
START WITH. OKAY SO WE'LL RUN
THROUGH ONE TIME AND THEN WAIT
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS- SO
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- ITEMS. ONE THREE SIX
EIGHT NINE AND FIFTEEN PLEASE.
ON CONSENT CALENDAR NUMBER ONE
WHICH IS S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE SB ELEVEN NINETY THREE AND
S. B. THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT. THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR BOTH VOTING
I. DOT. CONSENT CALENDAR SENATOR
DOT. DOT DOT HI. LIMON LIMON I
REQUIRE. MIN MEN I SKINNER. WILK. OKAY THIRTY SO FAR SO WE'LL
WAIT AND PUT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR NUMBER ONE ON CALL- SO
THE ABOVE AS WE MENTIONED-
BEFORE WILL HAVE TO CONSENT
CALENDARS CONSENT CALENDAR
NUMBER TWO WILL BE FOR THE
HIGHWAY NAMING RESOLUTIONS ONLY
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND CONSENT
CALENDAR NUMBER TWO. CONSENT
CALENDAR TO CONSISTING OF S. C.
R. SEVENTY FIVE S. R. SEVENTY
EIGHT AND S. C. R. SIXTY EIGHT.
THE CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR OF
BOTH VOTING HI. BAKER DODD.
DADABHAI LIMON. WE ARE CONSENT
CALENDAR NUMBER TWO THE MOBILE I
MCGUIRE. WITH THE WIRE I. MID
MAN I. SKINNER WILK. FOURTEEN
OKAY WE'VE GOT FOURTEEN LEAVE
THAT ON CALL AND SO WE'LL GET
INTO OUR AGENDA WE HAVE FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE BY SENATOR
RUSSELL I'M SORRY FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR BY SENATOR THE
DOCILE S. B. THIRTEEN OH NINE.
THE WORK. YEAH. SB THIRTEEN OH
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
BY THE VICE VOTING NO. PACKER
LIMON. LIMON MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE I
MAN MAN HI RUBIO. SKINNER WILK.
AND OKAY TEN THREE AT THIS
MOMENT BUT LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL AGAIN FOR ANOTHER ROUND I'M
SORRY WILL GO BACK TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO S. B. NINE FIFTY NINE
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND WE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CONSULT. I
DOLLAR I. BATES ALLEN. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA  OCCUR
BAKER HI COULD. DOLLY DOLLY NO
DOT. LIMON LIMON I MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE I BLENDED. MID MEN I
NEWMAN NEW I WILL. RUBIO I
SKINNER. MY CASKET WIECKOWSKI
AYE WILK. TEN TO ONE LOOKS LIKE
IT HAS ENOUGH TO GET OUT BUT WE
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL I
WILL MOVE ON TO- I FILE ITEM
FIVE SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR GLAZERS. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AND WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. THE
CHAIR. VOTING I THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING HI. ALAN ALLEN I WHICH A
LOT OF. ARCHULETA HI BAKER.
BAKER HI CORTESE. THE MOST.
LIMÓN HI MELENDEZ MAN MAN I
NEWMAN NEWMAN I SKINNER WILK.
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN ZERO THAT
LOOKS LIKE IT HAS ENOUGH TO GET
OUT BELIEVE IT ON CALL AS WELL
WILL MOVE ON TO S. B. ELEVEN
SIXTY ONE BY SENATOR MAN THAT IS
FILE ITEM SEVEN. MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT THIS CALL THE ROLL.
OCEAN IS DO PASS AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY THE
CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR BOTH
VOTING AYE. ALLEN AND I BAKER.
BAKER HI CORTESE. AMONG THE MOAN
HI MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE LINDA THIS.
SKINNER WELL. THERE ZERO AS WELL
LIKE IT HAS ENOUGH TO GET OUT WE
WILL LEAVE THAT ON CALL WILL
MOVE ON TO FIVE ITEM ELEVEN SB
ELEVEN OH FOUR BY YEARS GONZALEZ
MISTER CHIEF PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOST IS DO PASS AND
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR AND THE
VICE CHAIR OF BOTH VOTING HI.
ALAN ALLEN I ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I BAKER BAKER. THE
LIMON LIMON HIGH LINDA THIS. MEN
MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN. SKINNER I
CASKEY MY CASKEY I WILK.
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN ZERO THAT
LOOKS LIKE IT HAS ENOUGH TO GET
OUT LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL WILL
MOVE ON TO FILE IT TWELVE S. B.
O. TWENTY ONE BIKE. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR BOTH
VOTING HI. ALAN ALLEN I BAKER
BAKER HI CORTESE. DOLLY AMONG
LIMON AYE MCGUIRE. WHERE HI
MELENDEZ. NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE
SKINNER AYE CASKEY AYE CASKEY
AYE WILK. TWELVE ZERO BELIEVE
THE BILL ON A CALL NEXT SB
TWELVE THIRTY THREE BY GONZALO'S
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR VOTING HI THE VICE CHAIR
NOT VOTING. IT'S ALLEN. ALLEN I
BAKER. BAKER HI CORTESE DOLLY.
THE MOBILE LIMON I LANDIS NEWMAN
NEWMAN I SKINNER MY COUNTY. WHAT
CASKEY I WILK. ELEVEN ONE ELEVEN
ONE LEAVE THE BILL ON THE CAR. A
NEXT FOR ITEM FOURTEEN SB FIFTY
GONZALEZ. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE TRAVEL II THE
VICE VOTING NO. ALLEN ALAN HI
BAKER BAKER I CORTESE. LIMON
LIMON I MCGUIRE MCGUIRE I NEWMAN
NEWMAN AYE RUBIO. RUBIO. SB
TWELVE FIFTY ONE. RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE CASKEY AYE CASKEY
AYE WILK. ELEVEN ELEVEN THREE
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL.
RIGHT RIGHT SO WILL BE WAITING
FOR A FEW OTHER MEMBERS IN THE
WILL MOVE THROUGH THE AGENDA
ANOTHER TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE EVERYONE.
YEAH. ONE ON ON- ONE WORK.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS WILL GO AHEAD
AND TAKE A RECESS FOR SENATE
TRANSPORTATION WILL BE BACK
SHORTLY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SENATE TRANSPORTATION-
WILL RESUME WE HAVE GOT A COUPLE
MEMBERS WHO NEED TO VOTE ON ITEM
SO WE'LL GET THAT OUT OF THE WAY
AND THEN WE'LL WAIT FOR SENATOR
CORTESE TO. RECONVENE WITH US.
OKAY. OKAY GREAT.
GREAT THANK YOU SO WILL RESUME
ARE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE- WILL- ENSURE THAT
WE'VE GOT- ARE WE HAVE TO
SENATORS AND WILSHIRE WE GET
THROUGH THE AGENDA AGAIN FOR
THEM SO MR CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON-
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER ONE
PLEASE. ON CONSENT CALENDAR
NUMBER ONE WHICH CONSISTS OF S.
B. ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE S. B.
ELEVEN NINETY THREE AND S. B.
THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT THE
CHAIRMAN THE VICE CHAIR BOTH
VOTING HI. BAKER BAKER HI
MCGUIRE SKINNER. SENATE SKINNER
I. OF CONSENT CALENDAR NUMBER
ONE WHICH IS JUST- ITEM NUMBER
ONE S. C. R. SEVENTY FIVE ITEMS
UNDER FILE ITEMS AND I APOLOGIZE
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE ITEM
EIGHT ITEM NINE SB ELEVEN NINETY
THREE AND ITEM FIFTEEN SB THIRTY
NINETY. CAN HAVE AN AYE BY
SENATOR SKINNER SKINNER AYE A
SENATE MCGUIRE SENATE MCGUIRE HI.
OKAY SIXTEEN ZERO. AND THEN-
CONSENT CALENDAR NUMBER TWO WILL
BE FOR THE HIGHWAYS NAMING
RESOLUTIONS CONSERVATIVE
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ON CONSENT CALENDAR
NUMBER TWO WHICH CONSISTS OF S.
C. R. SEVENTY FIVE S. C. R.
SEVENTY EIGHT AND S. C. R. SIXTY
EIGHT THE CHAIRMAN THE VICE
CHAIR BOTH VOTING HI. BECKER
BAKER I SKINNER. WILK. FIFTEEN
FIFTEEN ZERO K. ADOPTED THE
CONSENT CALENDAR NUMBER TWO ALL
RIGHT AND THEN I WILL GO ON TO
OUR AGENDA WE HAVE THE FIRST OF
FILE ITEM IS FILEITEM NUMBER
TWO SB NINE FIFTY NINE BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AND WE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THE CHAIR VOTING HI THE VICE
CHAIR OF NOT VOTING. BATES
CORTESE DODD. MELENDEZ SKINNER
SKINNER AYE WILK. ELEVEN ONE.
ELEVEN ONE AND WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN. NEXT ITEM WE HAVE
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB
THIRTEEN OH NINE BY SENATOR TO
RUSSELL. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR VOTING II THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. BAKER BAKER HI. RUBIO
SKINNER SKINNER HI WILK. WELL WE
- OKAY TWELVE THREE SB THIRTEEN
OH NINE THAT BILL IS OUT. ARCADE
NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
FIVE SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR GLAZERS. MOTIONS DO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY THE CHAIR AND THE VICE
CHAIR PULLED VOTING HI. CORTESE
MELENDEZ SKINNER. SKINNER AYE
WILK.
THANK YOU COULD YOU SAY THAT.
REPUBLICAN OKAY A FORTY MEDIA BY
SENATOR GLAZERS FOURTEEN ZERO
AND LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL NEXT
ITEM IS FILE ITEM SEVEN SB
ELEVEN SIXTY ONE BY SENATOR MEN
. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY THE CHAIR AND THE VICE
CHAIR BOTH VOTING HIGH. CORTESE
MELENDEZ SKINNER. SKINNER I WILL. THAT IS FOURTEEN ZERO WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL. NEXT WE
HAVE FILE ITEM ELEVEN S. B.
ELEVEN OH FOUR GONZALEZ. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR AND THE
VICE CHAIR BOTH VOTING HI. DOLLY
MELENDEZ SKINNER SKINNER HI WILK.
FOURTEEN ZERO WILL LEAVE- THE
BILL IS OUT NEXT FILE ITEM
TWELVE SB ELEVEN TWENTY ONE
GONZALEZ. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AND WE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR AND
THE VICE CHAIR BOTH VOTING HI.
CORTESE DOLLY. MELENDEZ SKINNER
SKINNER AYE WILK. THERE ARE.
THIRTEEN ZERO LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL NEXT FILE ITEM THIRTEEN S.
B. TWELVE THIRTY THREE GONZALEZ
. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
HI THE VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
IT'S CORTESE DOLLY SKINNER
SKINNER AYE WILK. WHAT ONE
TWELVE ONE LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL. LAST ITEM FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN SB TWELVE FIFTY ONE
GONZALEZ. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
HI THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
CORTESE SKINNER SKINNER HI WILK. TWELVE THREE WILL LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
WAIT FOR ONE OTHER MEMBERS WILL-
PROCEED ARE TO GO ON RECESS FOR
JUST ANOTHER MOMENT UNTIL OUR-
OTHER MEMBER COMES BACK THANK
YOU.
WELCOME SENATOR CORTESE. THANK
YOU FOR COMING BACK ALRIGHT.
OKAY WE ARE ALL GOOD. AND NOW WE
ARE READY TO ROLL ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHICH.
ONE
YEAH OKAY GREAT THANK YOU MISTER
A SENATOR CORTESE NOW- MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANT WILL ACTUALLY
START WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
SB NINE FIFTY NINE BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR VOTING I THE VICE CHAIR
NOT VOTING. BATES CORTESE HI
CORTESE AYE. DODD MELENDEZ WILK. WELL 12-1 THAT BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE FILE ITEM
S. B. FILE ITEM FIVE SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT BY SENATOR GLAZERS
. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY THE CHAIR AND THE VICE
CHAIR BOTH VOTING HI. CORTESE
CORTESE I MELENDEZ WILK. FIFTEEN
VOTE SINCE I THAT BILL IS OUT
NEXT MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM SEVEN
SB ELEVEN SIXTY ONE BY SENATOR
MEN. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY THE CHAIR AND THE VICE
CHAIR BOTH VOTING HI. CORTESE
CORTESE I MELENDEZ WILK. FIFTEEN
FIFTEEN VOTES I IN SUPPORT THAT
BILL IS OUT. NEXT MOVE ON TO S.
B. ELEVEN TWENTY ONE THAT'S FILE
ITEM TWELVE BY YOURS TRULY
SENATOR GONZALEZ. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR BOTH
VOTING HI. CORTESE HI WITH A C.
I. DALI MELENDEZ WILK. FOURTEEN
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN SB THIRTY TWELVE THIRTY
THREE BY GONZALEZ. THE MOST IS
DO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR VOTING I THE VICE CHAIR
NOT VOTING. BATES CORTESE HI
CORTESE II DOLLY. WILK. THE
THIRTEEN ONE THE BILL IS OUT
FILE LAST ITEM FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN SB TWELVE FIFTY ONE
GONZALEZ THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
I THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO
CORTESE HI CORTESE I. WILK. THE. THIRTEEN THREE THANK YOU THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU SENATOR
CORTESE THAT CONCLUDES OUR
AGENDA SO THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATE
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION-
NOW THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.